he
thank you
[Music]
foreign
mic check mic check round what's going
on how we doing how we sounding how was
our level sounding talk to me real quick
we got the legendary Jake Solomon in the
building how we doing
let's see who we got in there beta
Cipher
Chicago you better ask for your cut of
marketing from for Access I'm not doing
that I'm just a fan big bad vote what's
going on Lucius Augustus what's going on
uh yeah nobody today audio is great
intro is frozen I know I know we're
working on it what's up with the music
the music will be coming I know I know
it's like a little a little out of
control today Nam what's going on man
good to see you good to see y'all up
here early uh Jake talk to the people
right quick little mic check
hey everybody
um I'm very very thankful to be here I'm
very uh
look I've known I've known the Lords
they're always very positive like a very
positive force right in gaming and for
for the games that I've worked on
specifically so yes I'm very happy to be
here and uh much appreciate it no doubt
what's going on attic talk to the people
hello hello can people hear me yes yes
focato says praise be Jake
phrase V oh they say turn them up a
little they want them okay they want you
okay they want you a little louder yeah
I can crank it yeah let's crank it a
little bit all right how is that yeah
there we go we want you overpowering
there we go all right that's good there
we go actually my my natural reactions
people want me to shut up so this is
better then that's good now this is
great this is great no doubt so we're
gonna come back we'll get y'all back in
here we waiting for SOB Waiting For King
and uh we're gonna have a good show they
got some fun we got the legend in the
building can't wait so we will be right
back talk to y'all soon
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep I'm Fred and Kruger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back leave
with messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still in
my Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look You Oughta messed up and
turned me to an animal and hell is be
swearing ain't real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
I'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being a cannibal and
they say I'm better than money because
you can Bank on me being accountable I
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable I kill a beating they
wanna compare me to Freddie and Jason
I'd rather be Hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all too Dramatical I know it's random
but I'm addicted to flipping and
sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start it
regardless and people don't aim check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social
[Music]
that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and hell is be swearing it real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was
[Music]
get back
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man
[Music]
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee vendor I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
carnito who cares if you fly if you
steal a mosquito you swear you ain't
something but really be Stevo you like
to collect stuff and that's cool but I
got bad news even if you really was that
joke King David still be the king of the
statue sister juvenile I'm encouraged
with a curse to be Musical and if you
hate it we'll meet in The Crucible other
than nothing it's cool and it's
beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday it's suitable cause you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord okay
[Music]
and we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast LLC and also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 305.
and it's another glorious Sunday we're
back at the round table on the Lord's
day and today I'm extremely excited
about our special guest and we've got
XCOM and midnight Sons to talk about
PlayStation showcase news Xbox ABK deal
approved in the EU plus Xbox and GeForce
now to discuss so we're gonna get right
what you're moving about I'm just saying
stuff sounds delicious
I see you you like some of these topics
oh man I can't wait to dig in it's so we
about to get right into it and what is
juice alone whose resume in the term
based strategy genre truly represents a
bucket list interview for myself and my
brother Lord addict now is this law
directly responsible for breathing much
leaded life into the turn-based
community but simultaneously evolve the
genre with tension-based combat strong
cinematic narratives and engrossing
strategy layers
introducing the legend and creative
director of both the iconic x-com
franchise and the resurgent midnight
Sons
the commander who revived turn-based
tactics kept us all stuck on OverWatch
and brought Marvel's version of Tinder
to The Abbey
live from Baltimore and kind enough to
make his debut into the realm of the
Lords my man Lord Jake Solomon how we
doing sir oh my goodness he wasn't ready
the higher he was a hype man
before I go into any business meeting I
need you to I need that I need I should
have recorded I got it I'm gonna go back
and record that
I got you mani's gonna be waiting for my
wife and my kids I'll be like listen to
this listen all right we got the legend
we got to show you the proper respect
here in the realm I appreciate that so
much and I'm very very thankful to be
here very happy to be here no doubt man
you're a lawyer what you do man I know
we've been talking you know pre-show but
uh you know how's things been before you
settling down and then also any games
you've been playing during this time
um yeah so I've I've been
been unemployed it's a weird word and
unemployed
um since late March I I I stopped
working in practices in late March so I
guess it's been six weeks almost two
months
um and actually so I you know you you
guys because of what you do I bet you
guys play constantly but I'm kind of
like a um because of my job I'm like an
up and down gamer I drift away you know
yeah and I swing to relate yeah
um but it's been nice because obviously
being unemployed I hate that being
unemployed
um it's given the opportunity to play
more games and so I will wait wait a
second Jake what did you say being on
unemployed yeah allows you to play more
games oh please listen in people yeah
people with this hardcore game what's
going on
[Laughter]
so you say because he's allowed to
because when you was working really hard
you know what I'm saying he was coming
in and out you know yeah so kids are you
implying when he was working he's
insinuating that some people haven't
earned their right game I'm like gay
all I'm all I'm saying is a lot of dudes
got a lot of extra time with their heads
and you know and Jake got some time
right now but he'll be right back at it
again no no no no no so what was those
games three live streams yeah
it's very true like um and especially
like when I worked right obviously I
played it
it's really hard for me like I'm I have
uh I'm a fairly obsessive like worker so
I've been I was saying
the car can I call you Cog it won't be
[__] no Cog is perfect you got to throw
the Lord on it every time
you know what you you know I mean you
don't have a clip listen this is going
in my resume I told you once you follow
me on Twitter and once you call me Lord
Cognito I can die right now I made it
all right
so my Lord my Lord
um
yeah I was just saying to you like I'm
not built for um it's actually really uh
like it's been tough for me like
mentally it's been tough me not to work
like I'm a worker like I'm a grinder
like I just am that is just my
personality is to is to work that's
where I really like find my Joys like in
working so it's been tough for me um not
to work and so when I was working I
would play it was hard not to play
either XCOM or mid nonsense whatever I
was working on it was always it always
felt like the wrong choice to play
something else right that should just be
playing my game because anytime I played
the game I would find hey we could make
this better we could fix this whatever
it is right it was very very it always
felt like the wrong decision to play
something else I got you um but now that
now that I don't have anything
um I have actually been playing there's
um a game called Rim World which like
really really like sucked me in like
I've been playing a bunch of Sims and so
I played playing The Sims I played
rimworld I played
um uh you know four Fortress stuff like
that so yeah and more Sim type games and
man room world like pulled me in like so
what you guys are like but for me I'm
always chasing the dragon right of like
when I was a kid and you get sucked like
when you play a game and you're like oh
man
I can't stop thinking about it yep I
wake up early in the morning to play it
like that doesn't happen very often with
me like a lot of times I'll play games
I'm like okay I've played some version
of this game a hundred times well a lot
of games I play I'm like it's fine but
but man there's nothing there is nothing
better when you play a game and you're
like oh that feels like like really gets
you and you're like oh man that's what I
want to do all the time there's no media
for me like books movie there's nothing
like games that were oh that's all I
want right so I did have that experience
with rimworld which was awesome just to
make sure that I'm still you know that
I'm still alive and you know I doubt
I'll get those creative juices I notice
you're implying Sims a lot but we'll get
into that later we will get into that
later but no doubt we got the Four
Horsemen of gaming those original Lords
of the realm here at the round table a
little bit of time sensitive intros
we're gonna get the most questions out
of what you mean well then give up your
time
[Music]
the difficult game conqueror Lord of his
own world and the how of the young wolf
Lord addict of the attic show how are we
doing sir
doing pretty good I've been playing a
lot of Zelda like an absurd amount of
Zelda
you know I still have a lot of the same
issues I had with breath of the wild but
I will say it's like a a step in like a
huge better Direction than breath of the
wild uh for the people that are saying
the temples are like the old temples
you're on drugs yourself damn they're
they're better than breath of the wild
but to say they're like up there if like
Wind Waker temples and breath uh not
breath and uh you know with sort Ocarina
a Skyward Sword had decent ones wow the
rare Skyward Sword blessing from addict
wow hey I already put that bomb down a
long time ago okay yeah you and King
have peace now with this guy with sword
yeah just like just like uh someone in
the time they're better they're better
than Divine Beast like they're above the
it's still like here here's all the
other temples here's the Divine beast
and here's where uh tears of the kingdom
is okay so they're stepping the right
direction and I can see the sandbox
they're making they can eventually start
to get the temples but fact where they
used to be with a little bit more work
that's positive it's overall positive I
respect that and of course we have the
most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single play a
selfish experience and also the soft
straddamus the Lord of clarity and Lord
patreon of the iron bank PC Master races
oh Lord sorry
wow doing well I wouldn't know because I
don't I don't play games oh use another
one those damn Lords don't play games
in my case they're actually not they're
not wrong
well it's real life I'm all about I'm
all about downloading games and patches
so my game's attached to to high heaven
they're great
theoretically they run grades
he's playing a game of life his
achievement score in life is crazy
you can get a car loan with that life
stuff
unfortunately I have not had it I'm so
mad I'm seeing all those people I'm like
oh I built Voltron and into the kingdom
I'm like
I have no context for any of this I have
not had a chance to play past that intro
part so that that's been my week I did
download uh I downloaded the uh the beta
for Street Fighter six because I wanted
to I wanted it to try out the characters
but the thing is like it kind of only
let me go into the story mode and I
didn't want to do that now I want to
wait for the game without to do that I
just wanted to mess around with the
characters and play you know verses but
um and I was uh
I got to play Street Fighter with this
let me pin that hold on
oh he's taking it back to the six foot
Genesis days
this is the Saturn goat pad remember
that oh my goodness I abandoned the
platform at that time
the Genesis ones the Genesis ones are
much smaller it's a pain yeah yeah these
are these are oh my God the greatest so
I'm the Charlie's not getting ready to
play
um and that's about it I I patched up
um Jedi Survivor oh my god oh oh I did
it burns beautifully because I had it it
was running well before right and I had
it running with uh you know Fidelity FX
you know whatever endpoint or whatever
it was like but now I was like all right
let me turn that off boom I was like oh
goodness I don't need that anymore
yeah it's looking nice it's looking I
can't wait to sit down and really play
that because just looking around like is
that just that opening area it's so
detailed and shout out to respawn shout
out to Patrick and the team we had him
beautiful game man it's good to see the
beautiful getting they did say the
patches were going to come as far as the
uh stability and stuff like that so
that's pretty much yeah and shout out to
the guys over at the bitcast that was on
the show this morning a celebrating 250
with uh with Hogue Travis and uh and uh
uh oh my god
[Laughter]
um yeah and we did a little bit of
trivia
like the whole Alex Trebek oh he did the
Alex perfect the long hair the craziness
but it was actually because the person
who lost last time had the host so it
was Travis hosting oh my God so Travis
came in with the tux the tux full-ons
look very spiffy very spiffy
um but Travis Travis is the game
reviewer yeah like he very much you know
goes into games on a very deep level so
the questions he had were sort of deep
Cuts yeah like nobody got yeah so uh I
came in third with four correct out of
25. I think I think whole came in second
with five he scored and then um and
boxing Burger King those are hard
questions
one of the ones I'm proud of that I got
right was 50 Cent bulletproof
and I I almost got it wrong because I
almost said blood in the sand and I I
remembered no Trevor said something
about PS2 era yeah so I was like no
that's not building the same that's it
I missed the Tyrese question though I
was mad about that sounds like Travis
was uh Travis is in his bag
yeah that's it that has been it no doubt
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the excess gamer the
prophet of Xbox
King of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium and experience it
is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved Lord King how are we doing doing
a whole lot better than your boy
lomachenko
shout out to Devin Haney shout out to
everybody man last night um
yeah yeah yeah he put that work in yeah
a lot of you dudes is upset like a lot
of you dudes is upset I knocked your
favorite YouTube out
oh no
oh no not the belt
kid come on I'm Undisputed for a reason
I do this you do this
so you guys just mad you can look for
the rematch later
wait that's the same belt back in the
day
the WCW championship belt that old one
is the best one ever there's so much
just gold
for context uh Lord Jake this is the
belt we used to do wrestling tournaments
in my house and this is about whoever
won the tournament get to hold the keep
the belt for the weekend for the week
that was the best we don't let this dude
dude get that belt for like 15 20 years
it's
I brought the belt and I put the belt up
for grabs for anybody that can get it
um and that's how you do that's how real
champions do you know anybody can go get
the Bell you can come take it let's get
it let's get it but at the same time man
that hold the line is looking really
good Oh you mean that hold the line yeah
so check it out check it out
check it out do Emoji y'all go hit that
go hit that yeah
members you get the Emojis oh it's in
there right now I want to see them hold
the lines in the chat shout out to Xbox
shout out to Aaron
Greensboro with this thing yes man I
mean I want to thank everybody in the
community that said I didn't play games
um I want to keep my name keep pushing
it guys uh thank you for all the
self-promotion that y'all been doing yo
I'm glad that I could be in your brain
and we can share the same brain together
um I hope this week is a better week
that I can get to go a little bit
further with hold the line in your brain
um yo the chat put mad hold the lines of
the chat they're usually emojis yo it's
crazy in the chat right now okay it's
doing it Go Go cop that merch is in the
emergency store right now um graphic God
oh God I sat down and did this um
really fast too man very fast he's when
he's enthusiastic about something that's
why I work with the same people shout
out to Dallas yeah
um rest in peace drum stall yeah yeah um
and graphic God that's that's my team
that's like my really go-to team at De
Niro canero and Sean labrae uh but
graphic God really had his pulse on this
filter look at the animation the cigars
the beat is great yeah y'all did that
yeah I did that um what I've been
playing this week uh here's the kingdom
okay whoo
um it's ugly baby but uh that ugly baby
definitely has uh something to it I
really wish because I I jumped to uh
Skyward Sword just to check he and
Skyward Sword is at a higher uh Fidelity
and it looks a little bit clean and runs
a little bit smoother but
tears of the Kingdom has some other
stuff going on um fortnite of course I
was playing a hell of a lot of fortnite
because of the Star Wars you getting it
in with that um that character did you
think yeah I had I was using Moon Knight
and that uh clip that I put up and I was
using the Darth Maul power it's it's
that's fantastic stuff fortnite I love
that game and I went back and played
some Jedi Survivor okay because I had an
update and it's running smoother this
game better be in for a game of the year
contention and nominations because uh
Jedi fall in order Mr cut by a little
bit and I thought that was uh criminal
yeah
and we could have had Jedi fall in order
and I think it could have gave uh Elder
ring a run for his money even though you
know God of War was in the bushes but um
you know Elden ring uh definitely won
that but it got worse in the bush it was
it came a second like I said
um but again you know I'm stoking the
Flames messy continue
um but yeah nah this year I think
Survivor should be there the game shows
a whole bunch of growth really good game
no doubt that's been it sir yes sir and
of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the Shinobi law Cognito spraying
that realness and around the IOP not
telling what you want to hear but what
you need to hear shout out to Friday
dude shout out to Mr Maddie plays had a
good discussion talking about the EU ABK
stuff shout out to ebonte shout out
Travis from the last word uh teaser
Teddy with the uh Cameo appearance
talking about the latest updates to
Destiny sandboxing UI changes as far as
men's gaming it's been tears of the
Kingdom uh Tekken 7 doing that on Steam
deck and a little game called water
chosen I figured time to uh get
refreshed back on one of the greats you
know so I've been doing that and it's
one more game I can't talk about because
I've been NDA dude and I don't want to
break that so but this other game I want
to talk about next week it's I'm
pleasantly surprised so we will hear
about that next week but uh Lord sorry
get the super chats explain the Rules of
Engagement yes the very patient Lord
Jake's Island ladies and gents you know
we probably you only have Jake Solomon
for a limited amount of time so I'm
gonna read these initial super chats and
then we will shut super chats down until
after our interview yes yes and then
probably want to keep the super chats
for when they can be messy anyway
all right so hold on a second let me go
into what I've clipped already we got
80s cartoon villain new members Dave
you put the crust in the chat for one
president
80s cartoon for them liking it then we
got Robert kellett five dollars if you
chat so you got the mid-sun legend
himself in the realm Cog congrats thank
you thank you so will 2K give you credit
for single-handedly promoting look I
already got my my present is here
I made it anything else is a cherry on
Sunday and Robert Kelly once again two
dollars to be chat thank you Jake for
making a great Marvel RPG hello
then we have Dragonheart Yobe member for
one year five dollar Super Chat that
belt nickname is called big gold let's
go
then we got project Aries new members
[Music]
now who thought that King didn't have a
belt
kind of Fates it kind of fits like this
you're talking about you know 30 years
ago here he's had we have zgl7 remember
for nine months Lord bronze Hold the
Line oh somebody just cop to hold the
line classic shirt I just seen it yeah
that's crazy yes
then we have let me see we got a couple
scroll down
um we got uh sagging nut sack oh he's
back
okay King fraud on you Loma got robbed
king
um on the rematch I mean I would tell
you don't listen to top ranks uh um Call
of the fight listen to my Call of the
fight and then watch it that way and
then you know they can do a rematch Loma
really wants it he can get back up in
there and try again you know next time I
say start off a little bit more earlier
you know don't try to wait to the end I
think he's acting by the way I think
he's acting after the fact because he
wants that rematch so I think in his
match with their acting yeah
I like that
he just wants back in so I'm gonna
do that dope then we got the Don cjg
five pound Super Chat hold the line the
clown man Association will never break
us
aka the CMA the CMA belongs in the
bushes you have a good show my guys
they're struggling about the deal
continue we have slow-mo back slap
remember for 35 months Lord bronze
afternoon Lords how excited is [__]
about today's death I have to admit
midnight Suns is better than I thought
by the way is Destiny 2 still broken
why you do a shot at my game man but
look I love what he said about Vanessa's
because you know Jake I may not I've
ever spreading the word that you know
people didn't give the game a proper
shot you know they thought they saw
cards or they got any feelings I know
and then when they played it it's on me
they played it to see so many people go
yo Kyle yo I feel it you were right
that's the greatest victory for me but
continue yourself continue There we go
Nintendo who upgraded his membership to
Lord silver thank you brother thank you
sagging nut sack once again you found
Super Chat fraud alert on King
reasons okay he's going back to the Loma
I know y'all wanted him to win so bad
but remember I told you in the beginning
of that fight if I was betting money I
was betting on Loma my heart wanted um
Haney to win
I needed Loma to give more uh and he and
he didn't and Devin Haney gave him more
of course all right yeah what else we
got
a gaming for a team member for 41 months
Lord bronze love you guys and I
appreciate the content especially while
working absolutely and as always hey
King Boo Boos hey Forte
the tradition that's why people don't
clown me on that yeah that's the funny
thing
part right there
caught up yes sir right let's get into
it man very patient guess you know now
we got what the Lord's been playing all
that good stuff we got to focus on Lord
Jake Solomon his video game system
history his journey into game
development and foraxis and of course
what led him to become the creative
director of the iconic x-com franchise
reboot and of course Marvel Midnight Sun
so Lord Jake they start from the very
beginning what was some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you into gaming
um
uh so my dad my dad brought home
so look I'm 46 years old
we're all there 47 40 on that wheelhouse
um so my dad brought home like uh like
an old like a PC IBM PC compatible
computer it was called an 808 and he
brought it home and it had a bunch of
games on it I remember my brothers and I
playing it and um
there were a bunch of games like weird
little games called like Jump Man and
all kinds of little games that I
remember playing
um but the the first game
and I think that I and I've said this
before but I do think it's true like the
first real game that you play it's
interesting because it sticks with you
forever it teaches you how awesome games
are but it's also that kind of thing
where you do end up finding yourself
chasing that Dragon for the rest of your
life yeah and for me that first game was
a game called Ultima five
so I played an RPG called Ultima five
and it was this had like a day night
cycle and I mean if you looked at it now
it looks so bad but I remember it's just
like
it just completely blew my mind like you
could talk to people you could type in
words you wanted to say to them and they
would respond and yeah cycle it was open
world like you could go around all this
little world so I remember that being
the first real video game that I played
that just really really like that's what
hooked me
um so I started on PC
um but then we had Nintendo and then
eventually we got Sega as well so I
started from the beginning
nice nice would you partial to any of
them like uh what was your allegiance to
because you know it was so we were a
Sega fan right so I knew I picked the
right here
[Laughter]
as like the the like title that came
with the Genesis it's all Sprites yeah
yeah power up yeah Sega and uh you know
it was the games that I remember
particularly on on Sega Classics yeah
besides Altered Beast and of course
Sonic
um I remember we played so I remember so
very soon after we got to Sega we got a
Sega game all right oh we're talking
King talk now yes crazy
um and I remember actually this is a
moment of Shame for me let's go
so Sega CD was like this big deal right
because you could actually put a compact
this skin you could hook it up to your
Sega and
um and I remember what my water was my
brother so there were these there was
this old uh electronic store called like
Electronics Boutique oh yeah we had this
yes okay so yeah again I grew up in the
midwest so I grew up like on a farm in
Kansas like outside of Kansas City
Missouri a town called Liberty Missouri
right
my little brother and I were like the
biggest gamers in the house and so we
and games are real expensive in fact
awesome games hasn't increased that much
actually correct exactly then they were
like 50 bucks right which I'm talking
about the early 90s right like late 80s
early you know
um so they're like 50 bucks so we could
only afford one game oh my God this is
embarrassing
the game that my brother wanted my
little brother wanted was something
called Sonic CD right okay yeah that's
dope
the game that I convinced my brother to
buy
was Marky marking the funky
Dr Sega CD Marky Mark full motion video
era oh no yes FMV like it was the worst
game it was the worst game it was so bad
and I convinced my brother to buy it and
I I'm telling you the truth when I say
that comes up at least once a couple of
years with my brother just throw that
back in your face repay the debt that I
owe him from taking him then they're
like you know we would only get a game
like once every six months wasted our
money bro Marky marking the funky
little Jake I gotta style you for a
minute because your story really
resonates because you don't understand
back that game's expensive right so you
got a tough decision and a lot of times
it came down to like that cover box art
or if you have a back of the box you'd
look in the back what is this thing bro
so it came today yeah oh don't bring up
the booty style but it's like
[Applause]
oh I guess for the next six months I'm
just gonna play this terrible game
I remember playing yes
they had the Kendo they had karate yeah
oh my God
yes I was something like that and it had
it was the EA the Box those they were
cardboard boxes the box art was dope the
box art was fire now that's how you sell
the game back then yeah and those are
the days of the the Sega Genesis they
had the different type of propriet Terry
cartridge with the yellow tag yeah and
you guys have taken me back I remember
Buddha I'm gonna I promise you I will
text my brother after this and be like
hey do you remember to come because I
remember that and you know that was the
best one okay yes absolutely I kick I
gotta shout out Lord Buddha himself was
in the chat the man who actually valid
card is in the chat right now he said
five dollars in the chat you gotta break
a protocol he said you guys are killed
it great work I'm very proud of you
shout out to for axis for the midnight
says love again he's the guy that we
Cloud because we all had buddy she was
like all right that's Sega Genesis you
get revenge Shinobi all right this one
because remember nobody got a lot of
money so you gotta trade amongst your
friends so you could ball so we like yo
get revenge of Shinobi yeah
he'd come back with buddhicon so Leah's
like oh man what's she doing we put it
on yes
same mistake
that game that no one wants right and
then realize you can't trade oh no
there's no get back on that it's no get
back that's the birthday you gotta go
like the cousin that actually liked you
at the Halloween party and like begged
to let it use it like oh it was it was
rough man that's what I said like I
laughed because I'm like I wish we had
Game Pass like bro it was it was rough
back then you you had to spend that
money you had that tough choice and if
you bombed you heard it like Jake heard
it from his brother
and it's true like you you really had no
idea because I wasn't reading magazines
or anything like that we played a bunch
of games but we didn't know right so you
just look at the cover art yeah you look
at the back and they're always like
completely different and so you go like
I don't know I guess this sounds cool
and you buy it I don't blame you on
Marky Mark because at the time Marky
Markle he's on fire the biggest things
right and to have that game if you like
his music and then you're looking at let
me let me embrace and let me embarrass
myself further
I've seen Marky Mark
live in concert
now it wasn't just Marky Mark it was one
of those like radio promotions when I
had a bunch of people oh it was like
summer like somebody was like CNC Music
Factory
um
you guys are my age you guys remember
there was a boxer named Tommy Morrison
oh yeah
all right tommy guns from from yeah from
Rocky um so I remember we were there and
we I saw this concert and it was Marky
Mark and uh yes and the Funky Bunch were
there
we're there and um I remember at one
point Tommy Morrison came out and they
both were like you know shirts off but I
was like but they're both yoked but like
Marky Mark is like five feet tall yeah I
mean Morrison is
he looked like a hundred feet tall
Jake no Tommy Moe wasn't doing the
dances with the yeah
I don't know what he Tommy Morris I
don't know what he was doing but he was
he did come out just yoked man recipes
the legend I think he was like uh um I
think he was from the air like okay so
again it was Kansas City right so
um I'm a country boy so he's he's a
young a small town uh country yeah yeah
that makes sense I think
Oklahoma Kansas City stuff like that
that makes sense nasty close to Tulsa
use a real boxing dude so yeah I am so
not as much now I was huge I'm a huge
fan of boxing I was for a long long time
I was a huge fan of boxing I started
because of whatever he started from can
I started because of of Mike right Iron
Man
um and then because of him I just
watched boxing from then all the way up
until
um I kind of got I kind of stopped
watching like the Klitschko brothers I
wasn't that interested once they became
heavyweight Champs I was like I was out
failed but um yeah yeah that's what's up
that's what's up his region
um is heavy into boxing like you know
like closer to Tulsa Oklahoma
um Deontay Wilder in them
um that's fight Capital like I think you
threw the um the the chitlin circuit
right so this is the fight circuit they
would send us through and we will go to
town to town to town and fighting right
um when you get to the chaplain circuit
down there they have small bars that
don't know these fights and I'm talking
about that's the Rowdy of the rowdies
and then you have the people of the Town
let's say you got a tough dude in the
town like let's say that's how they
found Tommy Moe yeah Moe was one of
those kids that will get in there and be
fighting grown men and that [__] was so
crazy that a promoter actually saw him
during the chickens chit in the circuit
and brought him through but these fights
and they go on all the time
my wife is from Tulsa I went to
University of Oklahoma actually oh
that's absolutely cool absolutely so
yeah so yeah yeah it was big yeah it's
really that's really interesting yeah
yeah that was I was really really big
into boxing so I still follow it now but
any any boxing games
oh my god
um so yes yes so you start with the you
start with the earliest right like punch
out and then then obviously Tyson's
punch out
um and I remember so my brother and I
and this is when he came to visit me one
time and so I love the fight night games
I love him
and the greatest thing about them is
that like I remember one time Johnny my
little brother Johnny he came out to
visit me and we just got in Fight Night
three so this is maybe 15 years ago yeah
um and like they had like we hadn't
played it at all so we didn't know any
of the you know any of the moves or
anything like that but they had this
awesome like opening sequence your
boxers looked awesome like they come out
right yeah
and so you pick these awesome boxers
we're like yeah we're gonna do like
Sugar Ray versus you know I forget
um but then your boxes come out they
look awesome and we just started mashing
buttons and they just looked like the
worst boxes of all and they're like with
this awesome intro then they come out
like just idiots
everything's just
you know yeah yeah I love boxing games I
love boxing games no doubt though love
loving to give is we're gonna move up a
little bit because we can spend all day
and there's so much stuff we got to
cover but um I did want to get into now
transition as far as like game
development and game design like you
know what inspired you what led you to
get into game design and then obviously
to for Access
um so I it was a
so a lot of a lot of times and I think
this is maybe this is trite to say at
this point but so many of the things
that happen to us in life are like just
they're just pure luck right like so
it's important to work very very hard I
tell my dog business all the time like
it's the the best attribute you can have
it doesn't matter how smart you are it
doesn't matter how it really matters
like how hard you work because when when
opportunity shows up you'll be there
right if you're a hard worker absolutely
um but there's so much luck involved in
success and the only place the only the
only place I applied to work in business
was for Access games oh wow I didn't I
didn't apply to a much but I I had
already accepted a job as a as a
business consultant I got a degree in
computer programming in computer science
from Oklahoma but I'd already accepted a
job as a business consultant and I just
do a
uh a business career then I do
Consulting and then I'd get an MBA and I
don't know just be some some
you know some a-hole just just business
you know whatever
um
and so I'd already accepted a job and
everything and then I but the one place
I applied uh a video game company
applied was Frances and that so there's
this guy named Brian Reynolds who was
this awesome designer he designed Civ 2
and he designed it's Legend all right
Nations he designed domination the
mobile game dominations he did he's he's
amazing
um but he had left for Access with a
bunch of people and his team has just
left to go form a company called big
huge games okay and because of that for
axis was basically decimated okay we got
it and because of that they reached out
to me way late like maybe you know
February or March where of of 2000 when
I already accepted a job my life was set
I was already engaged to my wife and
they re they emailed me like hey would
you be willing to come out for an
interview and I was like sure you know
that's fine and so I went out to
interview there and then the like the
minute I stepped in the building
and and I realized oh you can actually
make a job out of
I'd never back then it was like it
wasn't even it's just what it's not like
it is now where it's like everybody
knows about gaming and game development
like back then it was like this is crazy
they're Wizards I don't know how games
get made I didn't know
um but they invited me out for an
interview which it was pure luck it was
pure pure luck and but the minute I
stepped in the door and I started
talking realized oh my gosh I could make
a living making video games they offered
me way way my salary was way way less
than I would have made in business at
the big risk I just accepted it right I
mean like on the spot I was like
Absolutely I'll do it I'll do it okay
okay so so you ain't getting no I got to
get two persons you didn't get no
pushback from the wife like what are you
doing
that's a good point I should actually
have Jen come down
Jen is um so she's like she's got this
like Adventure or spirit where I knew
like when I was like look I want to do
this we'd never I didn't it was the
first time
I'd ever been to Baltimore right I knew
nothing about Baltimore came out here
seen a few and I was like no I I accept
the job and I called her and I said hey
look do they look hey look you know it's
bad but it's hey look hey look yeah yeah
I will say I've been married for 20th
years so you guys understand like if she
had said no way I would have been like
yeah you're right no way yeah okay it's
true like I know I know who the boss is
but he's got this real adventurous
spirit and so I knew she would be up for
it and that's love yeah she just she
moved out here with me wow because I got
married I took the job in May of 2000
and I said hey I'm getting married like
three weeks later can I just come out
after I get married yeah
and they were like no oh what yeah well
they're like they were so they needed
stuff like they were they were just they
they needed us out there to work on a
game called civilization three and so oh
that's a dope game too yeah you got to
come out and you got to work for three
weeks and then go home and get married
so I was like okay and and then it never
been out here and so I was the one who
found the apartment and I got it and it
was just a little small apartment in uh
in Baltimore and and so but yeah she's
she's got this adventure experience oh I
gotta stop kick like that's awesome
that's love right that's love right
there bro like you you kind of situated
already you're in a career already where
you're making more money you know gaming
has always been in the back in Mindless
dream but not only that you you coincide
this with close to being married and
uprooting your entire life to go to a
place you've never been and telling you
and wifey's like yeah all right I'm
riding I'm going sorry
that's a good point and I think people
don't
I always because I always thought it'd
be
not not corny but I don't think people
understand like how much
my wife like I you know and I'm sure you
guys are familiar but like you work so
much yeah like my wife from the
beginning has understood what the job is
and like how much I work and she's
always been like okay this is like and
we've it's been great for us you know
obviously our family benefits from it
but she's the kind of person who and
I've seen you know their their partners
that aren't and not that they should be
as forgiving but like Jen is just always
kind of like look this is what the job
is is what we do
like my wife holding the line yeah
that's holding the line yeah and so she
um like she we homeschool our kids even
like to the point where so she doesn't
work or anything like that and so in
order
for that yeah it's a ton of work it's
harder work than I do and and but it is
the kind of thing where in order to do
that Jen understands like all right you
know she is a huge any success I've had
I know I owe an enormous debt to her
because when it's like look I've got to
work all the time I've got to do this I
got to do that Jen's always like okay
yeah you got to do this you gotta you
gotta go and work I will make things run
on the home front
oh man gangster I love that look you
know what you know what level of peace
of mind that is when you know that your
partner got your back yeah and you're
working you're working in unison you
know left brain right brain left hand
right hand and your work together and
that that's that's what a marriage is
yes
um because like you said in the
beginning you could she could have just
said nah that's not cool right you know
you were getting paid more money you
were in your home base already in
probably the biggest space you got the
downsides your space downsize your
income and go to a foreign land for
uncertain situation but knowing that she
had your back made you work even harder
that's incredible yeah that's fine and I
wanna I wanna you know now transition so
they got you working on sieve I'm
assuming at that time Civ three
civilization three the first game I
worked on came out in 2000 came out in
the fall of 2001 I think but I started
in May of 2000 yeah okay so we got a
transition because now from this
obviously you know tremendous respectful
I Gotta Give flowers to the legend
Julian Gallup like he he is the OG in
this game you know soft will laugh but
you know there was this game that
basically like we talk about can come
with the belt we play the wrestling
games you know we play Halo four TVs in
the house right attacking there was this
one game that I decided to debut to the
crew Lord Jake it's called x-com with
PlayStation XCOM your soul defense
so I remember the PlayStation room but
you're talking you guys played Halo and
Tekken and you introduced you see what
you just said very different very
different games yes the disgust on songs
I never do this until recently how soft
hate it
but I'm like yo I got this cool game I
should check it out it literally all we
did was name our soldiers off the sky
ranger they updated every single person
and then it's like and then we we play
it like it was a multi play again so
king would be like okay move me over
there and then put me on Neil you know
OverWatch and then I'm cool and it was
this mini game between myself who would
survive in a relationship so we became
in factual Advocates I didn't like the
game at first until I spoke about
something happened what you saw I didn't
know this mechanic was in the game oh
the god panicked yes with the grenade
inside because he prepped the grenade
and he panicked and dropped the grenade
and killed killed the squad
yo and I said he did what yes and that's
that was probably one of the first times
because any other time you play a game
is a game I don't know what my brain was
thinking my brain was thinking like oh
this character is like alive like he got
scared
that made me more intrigued with the
game and that's when I went and brought
my copy they didn't know about that but
I went out and brought my copy after I
saw the Panic mechanism yeah
who was also part of this foolishness
that I brought to the squad so again the
legend Julian Gallup x-com the original
take me to the part now where you are
now either entailed with rebooting it or
are you pitching a reboot of the x-com
franchise I was so XCOM so again we
talked about like kind of you go in and
out of games and I remember high school
I'd kind of gone away from games and
then I came back because of
I think my senior year I was playing on
PC and it just really addicted me and so
when I when I joined for Access like
from the very beginning I was like we
should make Excel
so I was I it really is my favorite game
of all time and so I was like we should
make it we should make it and finally I
worked for Sid um Sid Meyer right so Sid
Meier
um you know if people don't know
God help you
he's uh one of the Legends and I was so
fortunate to work for him and he
mentored me as I worked for him uh on a
bunch of games as a programmer
but he mentored me as a designer and
because of that he at one point it was
like like 2005 or so he said hey you
know
um we should give Jake an opportunity
um and I said yeah what I want to do is
I want to make XCOM so he let gave me a
couple of other engineers and we made a
prototype of XCOM and um that was 2005
and it was terrible
it was bad bad it was enough to see the
vision yeah it was it was bad I mean it
was just bad and and so from from the
very beginning all I wanted to do was
make XCOM but I got that opportunity and
it was bad and like a lot of things in
life it's such a like it's the it's the
best thing that happened to me was it
would have been great right if I if
right out of the gates I'd made
something awesome right but that's not
life in my experience right and I made
something terrible
and what it did was it allowed me to get
a little more perspective on my own
abilities and what my real like and I
was like oh yeah I'm actually not I'm
not good at game design you know I
really felt like oh I there's so many
things I don't understand and I'm making
so many bad decisions and so
it gave me this real perspective where I
realized oh you know what I should
actually pay more attention to Sid when
I work with him after I made the
Prototype it was awful and everybody's
like yeah no we don't need to you know
exactly they laugh by man's out to build
it what what happened yeah it was bad it
was and it was I was kind of relieved
once I I showed it to them and
everybody's like this is pretty bad and
I was like it is pretty bad so I was
like you know what I'm just going to be
an engineer no problem
um but what it did was it
it taught me two things one was that I
realized oh I actually really like I
really liked making I really like
designing games even though I'm not good
at it but also it taught me like hey I
work for a guy who's really good right
right like hey maybe I should pay more
attention to that guy yeah so because of
that
negative experience like I got really
humbled and it's the best thing that
would happen to me right and then I was
like you know I gotta
I work with a guy who's a legend like I
haven't been paying attention to how he
does it so that humbling experience was
like everything for me that's like
that's what you need that was the the
start of me becoming a designer was
being humble so now where did we get to
the to the good version of the pitch
right so then after that I went to work
for Sid again as an engineer on
um a game called Civilization Revolution
which was a console version of Civ yeah
and this time because I'd been humbled
this time I like sorry someone's at the
door uh thank you that game's amazing
continues
um and the um so
this time when I went to work for Sid
and I was properly humbled then I I just
paid attention to everything he did and
I I watched it with like real honest
eyes not being like Oh I could do what
he does I actually was watching from the
eyes were like I don't think I can do
what he does I should actually attention
to this guy who's good and so I just
soaked up everything he did in the way I
never had before and it was so
instructive and so after that then Sid
was we got really really close Sid and I
worked together for a long time but we
got really close on that game and he
said hey
we should give Jake another opportunity
and so that is how it happened awesome
that's how he knew the young party one
was ready yeah
I mean I think he was like I hope he's
ready
he's like at this point if he can't do
it at this point I don't know I can't
help him anymore so you know so so
pulling up some some data from y'all now
you tell me if this was the original
pitch because you put this up on Twitter
it said oh yeah franchise Legacy IP you
know rabbit fan based tremendous
opportunity and then the premise was a
UFO abductions action and Role Play
Elements streamline design easy to use
controls interface incredible Graphics
that provide tension excitement and
endless play and you have these
different layers of the premise the
strategy to action and the role playing
link so this is now what you then send
off to them that is yes so I wrote that
for our publisher which was
um yeah it was take two 2K 2K and so I
wrote that for our publisher to say hey
look this this is the game that I want
to make but you remember at that time
like
turn-based strategy which is it has a
Renaissance now but like back then that
was crazy like Niche only successful
game that was like now they're great
Japanese games right so there were some
really fantastic Japanese tactics games
turn-based tactics yes
um so they did it better than anybody
but the only real successful turn-based
game there are probably some more but
really it was like Civilization right so
yeah
but it wasn't very common and so when
the publisher heard like oh you know
another turn-based game like oh no yeah
and so what happened was the question
Jake was there like a
like since the first one didn't work out
well for you when you was given that
second opportunity like hesitant to do
x-com again or or was it like straight
right back and we're doing it right this
time I'm like so how I'll tell you how
bad the first prototype was we didn't
even show it to the publisher
um so yeah so the second time but they
still were and and they weren't wrong
you know publishers
maybe deserve it maybe not right like I
feel like Publishers they have a job to
do right they have all this money they
invest it and they have to see the
commercial opportunity like absolutely
we're not
um you know we're not making like
you know it's not a it's not a um you
know a altruistic Venture like yeah you
have money right so the green light's
something that they think is is going to
be financially sound right yeah they're
like yeah if you yeah exactly if you
want if you want your team to eat right
like we need to make a game that's going
to pay so they saw a turn based and
they're like oh boy like I you know
they're they're like we understand XCOM
was a franchise a while ago
um they weren't super excited I'll tell
you what really sold them on it what was
it what was the deal well it wasn't
anything I did it was
um my art team and um my art director
guy named Greg furch who now owns a he
has his own studio and they're working
on uh a Star Wars
yeah so they're a company called bitrex
you guys are talking about them
as you guys are talking about like
falling or and stuff like that like
they're associated with respawn yes
um but
um but yeah so my art director he made
this amazing amazing video
um just yeah he made this like awesome
like
this is what the game's gonna look like
and you can find it online now and it's
it was so cool I told him I think the
game's gonna look like this and we we
worked it out between the two of us but
he made it look amazing and
um when we showed that to the Publishers
they were like oh turnbass could be if
you can make it look like this it'll be
you know so it was a combination of like
the art style in like the cinematics or
like like was that that's what kind of
wondering cinematic it was very
cinematic the art style was awesome it
looked really cool
um and so I really had credit and
actually a funny story about this so
when we were making that video to show
the publisher to get them to be all in
on this
um we knew we were going to use the
Unreal Engine and so we had
um
uh we had this these these contractors
come we had never used the Unreal Engine
before
ue3 at the time
ue3 okay but these contractors come up
to help us out and we've got these like
um
these guys from North Carolina so they'd
worked with epic and they were these
like nice guys like hillbill basically
right
um and
um I say that as a part like you know
I'm a redneck hillbilly guys I can use
the word Hillary
I shouldn't have said that okay
talk your talk Jake let's go all right
Lord attic are you from West Virginia
you can use the word hillbilly all right
let's go one could say I have more right
to say it than you do
this is true
so uh these guys came with they're
awesome and they helped us make the
prototype for
um XCOM the combat part of action they
were awesome
um and then on their last day there we
were all like partying drinking a bunch
of beer and just hanging out they were
really awesome guys
um and they had me play a game they had
been working on for years
and I played it and and it was this
little game you're driving these little
cars around and I remember playing it
and being like
this is you know this is kind of junk
but I really like the guys and so I was
like hey you know what you know good
luck guys I hope you guys have a lot of
success you know the houses probably
okay well to tell you to tell you the
truth it was rocket League
guys went on to make rock they are
psionics games they went out to make
rocket league and they made one of the
most successful games of all time which
should tell you a bunch of an idiot I am
this is trash I was like I didn't tell
them that to myself I was like this is a
junk game
it's okay Jake I'm sure there's plenty
of people I mean it was a pro yeah I'm
sure there's plenty of people that
played the prototype for fortnite and
was like this ain't it did that Battle
Royale I was like okay
original the original rocket League was
supersonic something car or something
yeah
yeah I've I've been so fortunate to have
so much
um success and everything the best thing
I could have done was been like hey guys
can I join you and your company and work
on this little road this little rocket
car game but instead I was like
um see that always made me laugh because
the the rocket League guy psionics they
were the guys who helped us make our
prototype and still so they went on
their way and I was so thrilled when I
saw what they made and it made me laugh
so hard when I was like that game I
played nothing and that's worth a
billion billion dollars let me ask you a
question they kicked that yeah I I
noticed may hit hard
did they say hey man you know um we
investing do you want to invest in
because I just had an investment issue
invested in Black Sans comic books and I
did it and I'm feeling the burn right
now so did they ask you to invest no
they didn't and if they had I I wouldn't
have been smart enough to because
can you imagine yeah what somebody put
in that company if some Venture
capitalists put money into psionics yes
they were they were telling us I
remember they were from North Carolina
they were like Hey we're going to move
our company we're going to like move our
company out to San Diego and and I just
remember thinking like these guys are
crazy they're just these contractors
helping me make x-com and I was like oh
you know I was like really like I was
feeling Superior and those guys went on
like crazy I saw somebody just sent me
so the guy who was the lead that team
his name is Dave hagwood he's awesome
somebody just sent me uh an article he
is in
orbs magazine because they have a
recurring uh article in Forbes which is
the super Yachts of the Rich and Famous
foreign
for us guys like a boat is a foreign
concept yeah but these guys that have
that money for no reason
they're like drowning in mind they're
like what can I do to get all this money
out of here
yeah so yeah somebody sent me an article
it was like him he used like uh featured
in Forbes like here's our monthly
segment on the Super Rich yes
this guy was like you were paying him
probably terribly just to be some
contractor just to be a contractor just
to get to get this that's wonderful I
love stories I knew another guy who be
the guy who went on to become the um CEO
of oculus right yeah Brandon aribe
worked for us as a contractor
UI software and he was just he was just
like really slick sales guy and I liked
him he worked for us for years and then
then you find out like yeah that guy
goes on to become the CEO of of oculus
which I got bought by meta for like
[__] dollars I was like I assume he's
doing real well he's doing quite well he
don't got a boat too yeah
bro this this team that's part of this
you know demo and and getting this stuff
out to the Publishers it's kind of
amazing to hear where things have gone
so you get this out they're blown away
with it you start working on it you get
the game out I know I know what happened
now Jake left because he wants his boat
yeah he ready
so it's like now you know tell me the
part when
you start to realize that it's either a
catching on or you're on or something
with um x-com you know Enemy Unknown
um so it was a really Rocky development
cycle um in fact we worked for a year we
met a prototype for a year with this
this team and it was something that
looked really cool but it wasn't
um like it wasn't fun so again I think I
had another failure as a designer to
make something fun and um that was
another really pivotal moment for me is
that we worked for a year on this
prototype and
there's nothing like
um
like I think the engine that kind of
drives me as a as a person and as a
developer is and I wish I could be more
inspiring but I just can only I can only
say what is true to me and the truth is
like I get I'm driven by this like
really fear of failure it's like a real
overwhelming feeling for me and so that
moment for me when we had made this
prototype and I had a whole team on my
back like expecting me like hey you hold
up your end of the deal they were doing
their part of the deal at the end of the
Cross and the artists were awesome but I
designed something that was not fun and
it wasn't a great experience and that
was like maybe the worst I've ever felt
in my life was having a team of people
who had worked so hard for a year they
and it wasn't their fault it was mine
and so I remember so again it was a
rocky Dome it's like but that was
another one where I said like look
you can get to a point where
um like I remember you know I was
younger and I pride is like the worst
it's the worst it is pride is down right
and so you can get to a point though
where you go like look
either you stay prideful right or you
you just go like or you're gonna lose
everything right I remember being like
you know what
I'm gonna have to redo to this design
and it's going to make everybody very
unhappy and people question my abilities
but what's the alternative alternative
you lose it all and it's a fun fun game
and everybody's not good right right it
will never sell copies of this game my
job is to make a fun game I didn't do
that so we have to go back to the
drawing board and it was the kind of
thing that that always stuck with me
like burned that experience like burned
the pride out of me I don't think I've
ever been prideful since because that
experience was terrifying for me it's
like oh my gosh like I'm gonna let all
these people down my whole career which
has been building this point
could have been like yeah you're
actually not you know you're a failure
and so that burned the pride out of me
and I said we're going to redesign this
thing and I remember we went back and I
redesigned
um something we called combat 2.0 I just
redesigned everything but that was this
sort of
at that moment that was just enough to
where when people played that second
prototype and it was
ugly and just these little gray boxes
and just moving soldiers around just
that moment was already fun enough
that's really what XCOM became in that
moment was was it came out of me being
like all right we're gonna redesign
everything and I have to do it as fast
as I can there's another moment where I
just worked all the time but what came
out of that was even in the early days
we were like oh this is actually this is
not bad it wasn't fun but you could see
how it could become fun right so so just
about like quickly I know I don't want
to get two of the weeds because you're
this Dev talk far beyond my scope but
like what were the key fun factors that
made the x-com reboot in your opinion
the changes that needed to be made
because to us this is the goal like I
mean I'm gonna be real with you like to
us like the Detention of moving your
soldiers you know the concealment aspect
and all that other stuff and and then
obviously we're getting that calm too
and all that stuff but even Enemy
Unknown Enemy Within I remember even
when you guys brought in the alien
rulers and do all stuff but like what
was the fun part that that kind of
turned the tide where even now your team
and then the Publishers like there it is
so it was very very simple it was
covered right so it was adding cover so
the way that games were the way that I
think about games is that there's all
these Loops right so there's there's
gameplay loops and as a player you need
something interesting to do every five
seconds and then you need something
interesting to do every minute and then
something interesting to do every five
minutes and then something interesting
that happens 30 minutes and then there's
a bigger Loop which is like the big
strategic stuff that happens every three
hours right so these big wheels turning
but the most important Loop is that five
second Loop like what am I doing that's
keeping me
from like turning this thing off exactly
like you know and so the loop was
cover can you every time you have a
soldier you've got multiple soldiers and
then
you it's not a super interesting
decision but it's interesting enough to
say where am I going to move this guy
right so it became like am I going to
move him into oh this is a better
position so it's really like cover and
flanking in fact you have like if I this
position's better so this position so
like every Soldier you've at least got
something where you're like right well
okay I got I'll move them all in the
cover and then that leads you to like
okay well now what ability am I going to
choose and and so that five second Loop
in XCOM is all about like it really
really every game has a five second Loop
Diablo has a five second Loop and it's
really really simple it's not complex
it's what is keeping you from like
turning off the game for the next five
seconds and so next time it became move
finding like a good cover position in
with your soldier yeah no absolutely
absolutely
no no I was gonna say I didn't have that
in the first prototype it's the first
thing I added in combat 2. it was the
idea of like cover
and then with cover comes like oh could
you get around the cover of the enemies
and that was it that was all I had in
the first the Prototype but when we
played it we were like oh this is
actually kind of interesting gotcha
everything in Exxon built off of that oh
nice no no you're absolutely right and
and to me it always reflected in the hit
percentages and things of that nature
when you move and you're like okay this
is a better vantage point I'm in a
better advantage and sometimes when the
alien's in a bad Advantage like okay
this is not strategic for me to continue
to fight them this way so no that that's
a key point and then obviously you went
on from that and then enemy within the
expansion right which was huge you had a
lot of gameplay mechanics and then you
know to me what also was really dope as
far as the customization of the soldiers
it really kind of personalized it and
you started to kind of get RPG mechanics
kind of slowly filtering into this game
so Enemy Within any thoughts on that
about that process and what was that
that you know just won an expansion okay
yes okay and look at the important thing
for me is to credit I had almost nothing
to do with anything okay so I got a
credit Ananda was the designer of that
and so the way we typically worked was a
designer would make the base game right
and then some other designer would make
the expansion so typically the guy the
second in command designer would get the
expansion
so Ananda joined me at the end of um
Enemy Unknown and he designed Enemy
Within and again it was one of those
cases where I remember the things they
were telling me about doing and I was
like this is something I've learned
about myself
I am very very bad at like being able to
critique others work like terrible in
that rocket League we continue yeah
my answer to everything is I would like
my answer to everything is like even in
my head I'm like well I wouldn't have
done it that way and that doesn't mean
it's right it means I almost can't see
another way of doing things and so for a
while 2K had me on
um like a board of of directors and we
would like review games being made at 2K
and I was like my feedback is like
pointless I was like every time somebody
shows me a game I'm like I don't I don't
know I wouldn't have done it I knew that
dude and it's it's 50 Brun I would say
with the with the cabin of like I think
50 of the time like I'm like I'm
worthless I'm basically telling you like
I'm wrong half the time I'm probably
right half the time but I'm right I'm
just telling you like I wouldn't have
done it I don't know at the time yeah
um so Enemy Within I remember they did
an awesome job in anything I came back
for x two so XCOM 2. let's get to the
goat let's get to the goat
XCOM 2 and and actually
um War of The Chosen I did design so
we're the chosen was an expansion pack
yes and it's the first expansion act I
ever designed and so games I loved I
loved X2
um I loved more of the chosen but the
funny thing is which I haven't talked
about too much but the fact is I
actually left XCOM 2 for about 10 months
in the middle of the development wow I
didn't know this yeah so I made xm2 and
then I left to make my publisher
um oh I don't know about this dusk yeah
yeah sorry okay yeah so my my I I work
for this guy who I love who runs Amazon
games now actually
um his name is Christoph Hartman he's
this awesome guy he um he ran 2K at that
time and he came to me and he was like
off Jake do you have
like do I have any big ideas and I said
oh I've got Big Ideas yeah
got those he's like let's do it let's do
something let's do something very big
and I said all right let's do it
um and so I left to make love Jake Jake
yes love it so I left to make
um a game that never got made it was a
game it was it was like Minecraft
basically like I love I still to this
day I love my I played Minecraft this
morning with my youngest daughter I love
Minecraft
um and so I I was gonna make my own
version of Minecraft and so I left for
like 10 months to do that but then
development on xm2 wasn't going very
well so
they had to call the guard back they was
like yeah
they canceled my project and said like
you gotta come back and and um and it
was great and it wasn't and it wasn't
the XCOM 2 team's fault it was one of
those cases where I had made I'd written
a design and designed a lot and then I
left and the problem with games is that
like
a design like you can write whatever you
want like it doesn't matter right like
right Design's trash like once you play
it the design grows into something
completely different right and it always
changes and they felt uncomfortable
it wasn't their design right you had the
blueprint so to speak right and so
they're like we must just we should
probably just do whatever he wrote when
the fact is if I had been there I would
have been like nah this is all these are
bad ideas let's just throw them out
let's do something new but they didn't
feel comfortable it wasn't it just was
not a fair situation I came back and
then unsurprisingly I threw out
everything I designed before and I said
look we got to do something new and
um Exxon 2 was crazy that development
cycle was crazy when I came back to
redesign so so much of the game
um but I loved X2 I really really
genuinely loved and then just wore the
chosen to talk about the goal let's go
yeah we're the chosen is part of the
game I'm um I loved midnight Suns but
maybe my fondest like I really really
loved one of the chosen because all
right so I don't know how nerdy you guys
are
super dirty I just showed you a
heavyweight championship belt I have for
30 years come on
come on
what I remember is um a guy who who
worked with me on on midnight Sons his
name is all right so you guys are you
guys mostly guys claim New York right so
yes sir oh okay so rock Rocco Chad Rocco
right from New York
old school like if he wasn't so he's a
narrative designer I've worked with
forever he's like my kids call him Uncle
Rocco like he's family to me that's
what's up I've known him forever
um but if he wasn't like a fair designer
he's like he would be like a bookie
the two the two guys I worked with on
the narrative two New York like just old
school Italian New York guys
oh let's go
the biggest character you've ever met I
mean he he like yeah he's the biggest
character I've ever met in my life but
he's he's awesome so we were working on
XCOM and and when we started working on
more of the chosen
um I was like he he mentioned uh a voice
actor so he always lined up all the
voice actors he's this voice director as
well and so he mentioned one character
and I was like whoa I was like I was
like Michael Dorne I was like that's ORF
I was like that's Worf Yeah Yeah from
from Star Trek next year my favorite TV
show absolutely let's go and I said
could you get um
yeah he's like this raspy like he's like
you know typical he's just like oh yeah
I mean I could make some calls I think I
could get it together and so he then
went and cast every actor from Next
Generation that he could
and he got
um so you know
counselor Troy and or all the all the
characters all the major voice
characters in one of the chosen are
characters from Star Trek the Next
Generation oh yeah and I remember when
he showed me this one scene where uh the
the actors who played uh uh Miranda
sernis who plays Deanna Troy in the Next
Generation Michael Dorn who plays Wharf
and they had this like you know
relationship in the show we hadn't seen
from them in War of The Chosen so he's
the reaper or no she's the reaper
character
I'm telling you when he recorded their
he recorded them and they put it over a
real rough cut of that cinematic and I'm
not an emotional without it man he
played that for me and I was like
tearing up walking there you go
I was like I cannot believe we've done
this yeah I was like by the way did you
tell them they'd be acting together I
hope they're not pissed off that we like
you know passed their entire show
they were super cool I'm gonna have a
shout at Lavar Burton
yes I know he's yeah Levar um
unfortunately uh laforge was too
expensive yeah
it's too much but I had Frank so I'd you
know I'd Commander Riker he was one of
them I'd um I had the guy who played Q
um so he was and so we have all these
all these actions but yes we didn't get
Will Wheaton and we didn't get
um uh we didn't get uh Picard and we
didn't get Jordan laforge because yes
he's got that Reading Rainbow money yeah
I need you to um
did you get pretty much like all the the
ones that you really wanted or was there
one that like couldn't get it
um so for me I think like Troy and Wharf
and Troy were pretty big for me I I did
want Will Wheaton we didn't get we
didn't get will Weeden
um but yeah no we we got it was just it
was like a really fun moment and I'll
tell you were the chosen was a game it
was the first expansion packet I ever
made so if people like you make a base
game and then when you make an expansion
pack right you kind of go all right we
already know how the game works it's
really fun to design because you know
how the game works you know what people
like and what they don't like and you
get to just add more and the team is
kind of firing on all cylinders and so
that's one of my favorite memories is
designing for the Chosen and working on
them
okay yep I was um you know you mentioned
that the way 2K does things where you
know uh the uh the second seat pretty
much does the you know the expansion
stuff is that like to put you on the
primary project that you guys are doing
next or because to me it's like getting
you on that next project but also like
passing it Forward where the other
person gets that opportunity yeah okay
how does that is that like an industry
thing or is that like just a 2K thing
um it's Pro I don't know if it's a it's
maybe it's just a foraxis thing but it
always for us it's always been twofold
as you said one is because I need to go
into the next court right that's that's
always the very big expensive thing I
need to work on that before I have like
150 people right like to focus and and
work on that without a huge team and
then you also want to see if the people
the second in command people do they
have like jobs hey are they are they
ready to take off expansion pack which
isn't that's a good way to use your job
but it's still a tough job right so yeah
and so if they do a great job there then
all of a sudden you have confidence like
oh good we've built up a bench here
right so that's kind of it I want to
give you you know I know we're gonna
move on but I I have to give you your
flowers of water chosen you know that
that to me is the Pinnacle of turn-based
strategy you know that to me I'm I'm be
honest like because one thing I like
about it is brutally challenging in the
beginning but the sense of turning the
tide then you've got you know the
tactics you got the complex system
you've got the base strategy layer you
got the faction the covert missions and
it's really menacing you know what I'm
saying but it's like especially when the
chosen appear on the map when they
chosen appear on the map it is the most
disruptive thing to get through
especially on those missions when you
got like a tie timer and things going on
so it's like it was so much going on to
it but again like me and addict was
playing it and turning it tied another
thing I want to give you flowers with in
terms of what it chosen it and just
x-com your reboots in general is to me
you guys had the narrative layer in turn
base and I think a lot of times the
reason why people sometimes get
disconnected from turn base is like yeah
you got the soldiers you got your
connection to that that's for us Geeks
you know nerves we love that but when
you have that story you know the
commander we got to get him out we got
to do this and now we got to change the
tide and now we're doing these facts
it's something about like the narrative
aspect of the Cinematic Flair the x-com
that I think that you guys added that
really takes turn base to the next level
was your thought process part of the
question on um what it shows like to
kind of get that or was like who was
responsible for like so much of the
cinematics and the narrative aspect
that's Rocco that's Rocco
yeah that I credit Rocco with that for
sure I mean I I'm always the kind of guy
who so midnight tones was different
because I'm such a
um very hardcore Marvel comicator but
um on XCOM I really I really credit
Rocco with um he was and they had always
had a hard job because I would design
and I'd say like all right this is the
design of the game and uh you guys need
to make a story
this needs to happen here this needs to
happen here
and it wasn't fair like that the writers
and and rock had to like just be like
okay
um do this here and I'd be like nope you
can't do that they're like okay can we
do this here and I'm like okay we can do
that there so midnight Sun's obviously
very very different much more narrative
game where we worked much more like from
the beginning Rock and I work hand in
hand but um yeah Rocco deserves all the
credit for um or the chosen's um
cinematics yeah narrative like he's he's
he's the best obvious I was gonna say
Obviously you know there's a lot of you
know games that are putting turn base in
this front and center but I would give a
lot of that credit to like you and your
team for making it more mainstream
because up until XCOM at that time they
were games but I never really saw like
AAA games taking like risks in terms of
turn base yeah then when I saw like the
the x-com success it felt like it gave
okay there is a demographic to people to
play these games yeah no absolutely and
to add on to what attic is saying what
one thing I really liked that your team
did is the kind of like the soldier the
bonding system you know what I mean and
it's like okay these two are together
like and then you get these extra it
really delved into RPGs and deep
mechanics and you really kind of like
you cared about the characters you know
what I'm saying because they used to
watch them grow together and the last
thing I think this is your team correct
me if I'm wrong was I love when you did
the tired mechanic because to me let's
be honest once you get your five or six
those are your dudes and you rolling
with them five or six powerful dudes all
the time but now it's like okay I gotta
rotate dudes out I gotta strengthen that
oh sometimes I'm gonna throw this person
in the psionic lab or whatever so you it
forced me to play with the whole Squad
whoever was the the the founding of that
feature I hate that person Jake was that
you
yes and it was a case of and it really
is a case of and you that's very it's
very um well yeah your Cognito it's
cognizant of YouTube
that so many of the mechanics we we did
in EX in more of the Chosen and also in
Midnight Suns was always to force the
player to take different characters
because what would happen is that you
really have to we always call it playing
the hand you're dealt we need players to
play the hand they're dealt because if
they can control the more they can
control the more samey their experience
is going to be from minute to like oh
yeah I've got this build I like and this
is true for any game if you get into a
run where you're like I've got this
build that works well for me right right
and I play it the same way and then the
player will say like after a couple
hours they'll be like
why is this game not as fun anymore well
the reason is because you're playing the
same experience over and over and over
again it's like the player's fault it's
the designer's fault for letting the
player get to a place where oh yeah I
can just enforce my will on the game and
then do that like because the player has
been taught to achieve success well the
best way you can do that is like to
force your will by saying like yes these
six Squad members if I take them it'll
play out exactly the same way and I know
exactly what ability to use and if the
player does that they're going to bore
themselves and so so many things we did
were like force them force them to say
like ah you can have four out of the six
you want but you're gonna this rookie
and this person who you probably love
but they'll create a great memory for
you or whatever it is yeah no absolutely
it those are the rookies that become
Heroes would you like come on bro you're
the worst of the squad I need you to hit
this shot right here I need you and then
if they succeed you're like all right
you know you build them up so I love it
the nicknames and all that we could go
on about X car man tremendous game now
before we get I'm sorry
no just I can't wait for midnight oh I
was about to go I'm about to go right
there I was about to go
get something for him oh okay okay one
quick question before we get last
question before we get to midnight we're
here for a lot of us
um shout out to the Lord Mark daughter
who we had on during Chimera Squad right
yeah now the question I have is you know
cameras used to be you know a very side
Pace breach mechanics very cool game but
a lot of people also was like yo why not
XCOM 3 at that time so like what was
quickly I don't know if you were
involved with it but like what was the
thought process for the studio to say
okay Chimera Squad after World War The
Chosen and then obviously then you go to
midnight Sons but what was that whole
thing about I do have something to add
on to it real quick that I'm sure the
console people why no hey why don't
matter Squad in the damn console we're
blaming you for the publisher why is
this
not my choice
um yeah Chimera Squad that came out of
the fact that so we had
um someone with the chosen we had just
started and Mark actually started on
um midnight Suns right so you started
with me on midnight Sons I think the
first time I worked with him was on x2
and then more of the Chosen and then we
went to midnight Suns
um and then we had this opportunity
where
again it was a case of the team was just
let's see how much can I say here all
right so let's talk about it I had been
so after War of The Chosen I I midnight
sons was the opportunity but I just
there was just a full team and that was
the problem so the challenge was that I
designed so unlike in previous expansion
packs
um like typically it'd be like somebody
else would design the expansion pack but
we weren't at that point so I designed
X2 and then I designed the expansion
pack as well what that meant was that I
did not do any work on a follow-up
product got it and so when I got to
midnight Suns which I desperately wanted
to do I had a whole team and that was
that's just that's too much right like
very it's very costly it's very wasteful
and so we said well there's an
opportunity here and and Mark was
obviously a great candidate for that
where we said look have an opportunity
to
do something and so they were going to
continue off of like kind of off of the
war The Chosen code base they went and
did the wrong thing
um and that design was you know I was
totally you know he deserves all the
credit for that awesome yeah he's
awesome and so
it was a case of we had this opportunity
and we also had a huge team on midnight
Suns and so I think that's the way it
worked I think there was another project
that
also stopped at that point so we had all
these people floating around and it was
like Hey look you know 2K asked like hey
what do you guys have and I think I said
hey you know Mark should get an
opportunity to um ah you coincide the
young goat all right I did it that's how
I got we love Buckner that's how I got
it yeah Mark's great Mark is awesome
um and so that he went and did Chimera
Squad but it wasn't but we didn't have a
staff to do and and most of the XCOM
team was with me on midnight Suns yeah
so we couldn't have done we could not
have done X3 because that team the x-com
team was my midnight Sons no I got that
but why no console port for Chimera
Squad what happened I don't know email
what two emails
because it's like we listen like this is
where I got a sideway attic it feels
like if you're a turn-based level on
Console PC get it then you got to wait
like a year then you gotta like like
it's always always you guys gotta wait
because gaming in the Stream is really
fast yeah it's like once once that those
initial ports are through even if it
comes down the road to me all the energy
is gone you got the hardcore people that
might buy it but you ain't getting no
stranglers and no no I'll get you I get
you well the bigger Market is in the PC
to be honest with you when it comes time
I feel like a very niche market so
clearly
I mean XCOM 2 didn't come to consoles
day one but I do feel like it x-com
Enemy Within and uh you know Enemy
Unknown did well enough to even make
them validate putting it on Console so I
feel like there is a a market on cost
it's like but like sometimes like it's
it's the you know are we gonna make the
money is it worth it it's a lot it's a
lot of like gray area
all right so we got to get to the main
event like King said
a lot of us are here for you know what
I'm saying um look we gotta talk about
that being nice Sons yeah so you're
working on this you know first of all I
absolutely adore the game as you know
you know it's it's tactical it's
cinematic in nature the one thing I
really enjoy about it is the the way as
far as from a deck building perspective
for the character you play into the
characters ethos and personality like
Iron Man he wants to do self himself he
got to read to read draw mechanic and
all that stuff you know storm who just
released you know she's very powerful
but everything all her powers are like a
build up you know next turn she'll do
this it'll be stronger and so it's like
you really get into either of every
single character you've mentioned before
this was a dream project of you as king
said you know you're a Marvel head
you're a comic book guy so the first
question you know like for this for King
how hardcore are you with your comic
game and then the second really hardcore
okay let's go let's go
do you know about this
oh
is this um what do they call they call
this um
yeah right it was Captain America and
Superman had a and it was the um what do
they call this uh no no this is not the
amalgamation this is what I'm thinking
this this is our era all right so in
this era you know we had those giant
sized books so this is why the book is
really large right so I had the Batman
versus uh the Hulk here I got the giant
size uh Spider-Man
and you know I got Spider-Man versus the
Hulk yeah
um I don't know where my Muhammad Ali
versus Superman oh that's classic but uh
I got Spider-Man versus Superman yeah
um and you know this is you know and
they go against Dr Doom and the parasite
and this one is all your classic
team-ups you know Hulk versus Thor you
know you know the Fantastic Four and
stuff like that versus The Thing I can
see Neymar there with this yeah huge fan
um and and I know this is probably jump
in the gun yeah
is there one character that's on your
list that you didn't get a chance to get
to yet or you want you wanted to get to
that you didn't get a chance to get to
and put in the game that is one of your
favorite characters
um
okay so the game's been out long enough
now right let's go
that if I if I give spoilers okay maybe
I don't even want to say but you could
say so one of one of my one of my
favorite characters
um is is Victor right is Victor Von Doom
right oh yes I got a cell right here
and so here's the thing that I feel very
strongly about
um you know and I've had this
conversation and so my relationship with
Marvel was was awesome and they've
they've actually I I should say I should
shout them out they've continued to be
helpful to me even in the situation
where I said hey I'm leaving for axis
and you know I want to set up my own
studio and um
they've continued to be helpful to me
and reach out because we were so close
making the game
I got a credit like Jay Ong who runs
Marvel games like he reached out to me
afterwards I was like hey he's like let
me let me help let me introduce you to
this person
and he's like I know you're not gonna
you know you're not making a Marvel game
he was like but we we consider you
family because you made a game that
we're really happy you know my team
loves you and you made a game that we're
proud of so he continued to like help me
after the fact so this Marvel game guys
are they are so
um but what I I have these um
conversations with and so my
relationship with Marvel games was
always great because I was such a Comics
nerd yeah that we always spoke at the
same level of like very hardcore like
very the minute I talk to them about
stuff they were like oh okay they're
like um you know they were like oh
you're you're one of us like you're a
super [__] ass
and so what I'd say about
um Doom
is that I never consider like Doom to me
is not interesting as a villain where
Doom is interesting is when he Doom is
always a best character where you have
to work with him right right as an as an
anti-hero that that's where Doom is
interesting not as like Doom's the bad
guy that's not true like Doom is not an
evil person Doom is at his best when he
is like this sort of um reflection of
the characters he works with so it's
really fun to think about like man what
if we had had like Doom working
alongside Doctor Strange or Doom working
alongside Iron Man that to me is like
the is the the magic is being like and
also Doom is very funny right he talked
about himself in third person and can
you imagine having like a pool date with
Dr Doom
like I love I love Doom because he's
this tragic figure and also he is this
like he does have a noble goal to
protect his his people his people right
he's protecting his people he he's out
there and so mm-hmm for me I've always
loved Dr Doom is like one of my favorite
characters
this guy is the greatest
and that's where I think where people I
I always it always like makes me
you know when I see people talk about
whether it's the MCU or whether it's in
games people talk about Doom as a
villain I'm like he's not available
[Music]
a lot of midnight Suns is about Magic
versus technology right it's yes on the
on the evil side it's the technology of
Hydra with the the lilin and Lilith and
then we said it's doctor strange and
Iron Man it's techno magic it's working
together being at odds coming together
and so we were like who is that more
than anybody what's Doom is like the
perfect perfect boom would have solved
he if he went with love he would have he
would have ruin the heroes if you want
the heroes they would have had an easier
time right so yeah Victor I I just love
I just love him and he he's cool I'm
sorry I'm gonna no no no no no
you're in your bag this um he has this
great storyline where his his um his
mother so his mother is trapped in Hell
by this pistol right and so he has this
thing where every year on the same day
every year he goes to war against all
the the demons in hell and Mephisto
um and I just love that story of like
Victor really like what he he really
wants to do is save his mother and
there's this great probably my favorite
comic is called Triumph and torment and
it's a doctor strange team up with Dr
Doom to go rescue his mother and he's
like
Doom is like he's just the he is just
the coolest character so it always bugs
me when people talk about Doom as a
villain because I'm like yes he's a
villain but he's better working with
he's better but yeah that's not how he
should be so yeah our plan yeah my plan
um for doing I have no idea what they're
gonna do but my my plan for Doom was
always like yeah Doom should not be well
you've you should be the bad guy for
like a little bit but then eventually
you got to work but to your credit for
those who have the season pass it was
eluded that was not even alluded to his
straight up kind of hinted with who
Deadpool is Deadpool has a client I love
doing Deadpool yeah he was awesome
yeah Dolan North on The Voice on that
one right yeah
Rocco getting all the big days man you
had Nolan North you had some names on
this this project bro and
um I should also shout out because you
guys called out Fallen order as well so
the um actress who played the hunter yes
the female Hunter she's all also New
York's her name is Elizabeth Elizabeth
gruyon or something like that okay but
she was um she was the villain she was
Trilla in um Fallen order
that was Rocco was like dude we've got
to have she's got to be something we
gotta give Rocco his flowers oh my God
he out here doing the Lord's voice
Rocco said forget about it
he is he is a he is a he is a true
character you've never met a character
no no so I got back up so okay now
you're doing this I'll get you off of
ex-con this is in the the new the new
project
what is the pitch to foraxis like
because I noticed your dream project but
like how do you get that and then as far
as like Marvel getting you to trust this
license of all these characters like
this is a big deal they don't just give
that license away you know yeah they
they it was Marvel actually came to us
and so because Marvel
um and and again this is Jay and and
Luke and
um Tim all these guys at Marvel they
were really big fans of XCOM 2. so
and so this is the kind of thing where
you you hear this sometimes you'll meet
like gaming Executives right people who
are
high up in publishing or whatever and
they'll be like oh what did you work on
and I'll say um well you know I worked
on a game called XCOM and they'll tell
you like they're like oh yeah I love
that game that's right and you're like
I appreciate you saying that but you
never played that game but Marvel came
to us and I had my first call with
Marvel
um James the games team just me and the
Marvel games team
and they started like talking about XCOM
2 like in detail that's right they had
like detailed feedback on like the
ranger class and a problem with the
range I think this was Jay who said this
again this is like a vice president at
Marvel five yeah and like he was like
you know the problem is that you know
you you they're great but when you you
use them you know they pop too many pods
like they reveal too many enemies I mean
I was like criticism and I was like oh
my God I was like this definitely plays
the game I was like that's actually Fair
feedback and so it was like a match made
in heaven because I was really hesitant
to the the truth is I was actually very
hesitant when Marvel approaches it first
because I thought I never worked IP
before right and I never had anybody
have any creative control like so 2K as
a publisher
never ever ever exerted any creative
control like all the creative decisions
um were ours and so ultimately as the
curator they were all mine and so I
always was more comfortable in that
situation I thought man I love Marvel
like right I really really love Marvel
but I don't want to be in a situation
where I'm working for somebody and they
can like affect if I can't make the best
game that I can because somebody's like
oh no Iron Man wouldn't use that ability
I'd be like look I can't do this right
like yeah I feel really worried about
that but then I met with them and I
actually felt them out in my on our
first call I introduced the idea of the
hunter on our very first call I was just
about to go again yeah and I said look I
I would like to have a customizable
character that would be a superhero that
we get to make and the player gets to
make
um and you guys have never done anything
like that like that idea because that
was my way of basically like like poking
them and if they said like oh I don't
know about that I'd be like yeah I can't
work it into it not because you know
they can do it they they have a billion
billion dollar IP they should do
whatever they want to do but I knew it
wouldn't work for me right but the
minute I said that to them they're like
well we've never done that before
they're like but that sounds cool like
let's do it like we want a gift and I
was like okay
um I'm sure making your own character
was easier to to keep them at Bay when
it comes to like their characters
because a lot of the stuff you did with
your character didn't really resemble
any of their characters to that degree
yes and the the challenge though was to
to what Marvel always said and I agree
was they were like you're gonna put
somebody they're like so
you have a game you have like you have
some heavy Heavy Hitters right you got
oh Spidey the most popular character
right right so you've got these
characters that have a lot of meaning
for a lot of players and especially for
the Marvel team and they said so now
you're gonna
put somebody next to them and basically
going to take a lead take to make them
yeah yeah and they said they have to
stand up shoulder to shoulder and you
have to buy like if we're co-signing
this Marvel character like making a new
Marvel superhero and they're like that's
they don't even do that they're like
that's very rare we don't need to do it
in the comics right now that's ambitious
but we just don't do that and they said
so if you're gonna do that it's going to
be this
um there's gonna be this challenge to it
but again they were always it's crazy to
me that Marvel games they control the
most powerful narrative IP in the world
right but they were more excited about
like we want to help you make the game
you want to make they were never like
that's impressive because I'm glad attic
asked a question because that's why I
was thinking to myself like you know
having the hunter this carry the
character and salute to the voice actor
and actresses that play because they
they're amazing because it comes from
the player perspective like
talking like especially if someone
doesn't know about Marvel heroes and
they like so Wolverine like why do you
you know tell us about this spot like
like it's asking them about their powers
so it's coming from an uneducated
perspective because this person's been
dormant and dead for all these years
whatever and then but to your point I
thought it was interesting that you said
that you didn't want to do it if it
would have been just a traditional
Marvel story where it's like okay play a
spidey in Midnight Sons or whatever that
didn't interest you what interested you
was actually the Hunter and then the
two-part the second part I have to ask
is in reference to now we had a bit of
the controversy is where
let's be honest you come from tactics
traditional right this is tactics but
this is also cards right and then attic
I'm put you on the spot because we're
gonna be real about this spot you know
my brother you know wasn't really sold
in the beginning because he was like the
no cover because we talked about cover
earlier and how important that was for
you to get you know x-com kind of the
reboot through the door and then and get
that solved so like how did you deal
with that kind of changing what you're
known for on its head with midnight
sense in that regard
I think that
so I I think that part of it is is
probably me being
a little naive in the sense of I just
always believe
let's just make the best game we can
right like let's I maybe maybe too naive
frankly where I just go like I I think
the best thing we can do is make the
best game we can like this I am
it is that is the closest thing to
gospel for me which is like people
always make a decision that makes the
best game possible whatever is the most
engaging fun addictive experience like I
will bend over we will we will bend and
break every rule possible to make that
because
I just think that that's at the end of
the day that's what matters most
definitely yeah um and so but to do that
though and again I say that I'm also
maybe a little too naive in that regard
because yeah the cards that's 100 that
was a hundred percent me and I was like
it's fine I was like it's cards you know
like and yes it was like very much a
reaction when it when it first like
huh what the hell am I looking at here
like and I was like yeah people get over
it it's the best and I mean again I do
believe like it was the best mechanic
um but at the same time I don't think I
properly appreciate like yeah it's a lot
to take I mean it's a lot it is really a
lot for to be like okay you're making
your Marvel game great what kind of game
is it well it's a it's a turn-based game
people go like already face right there
there's cards all right there's cards
actually you know and so some people
immediately go like wow
kids I think the biggest thing with it
is is like when people are like oh the
x-com developers they're making a Marvel
game people naturally and I would say
within right would think it's gonna be
similar to x-com and I think that's
where the disconnect was I this is so I
remember so I remember it actually
leaked right so it's actually because
yeah I I remember
saying that they were they didn't say in
the beginning
that's where my face came in yeah yeah
no no and I look I yeah and that's I
remember when the story leaked and it
leaked as Marvel they leaked as Marvel
x-com and I remember so this is and
again I don't I don't want to over
dramatize the story but I remember I was
with my mom my mom was sick right my mom
and I was with her and this was like the
last days right so I was wrong yeah
sorry so I was out there with my mom and
California with my siblings and all of a
sudden I got like a bunch of alerts you
know like phone and it was like already
like a tough time right and so it's like
okay okay all these and it's like
Marvel X coming I was like oh God I was
like did they call it I was like that is
the last thing I wanted it to be called
again I don't think a lot of people read
those leaks but enough people read them
that in their mind they go like oh
Frances is making a Marvel XCOM which is
absolutely not what we wanted it was and
I was like man I wish we could have
controlled that message a little more
because when that leaked I was like oh
I was like I get you please that's the
last thing you wanted to have that data
but in his in his defense you can't have
a Marvel x-com because Wolverine is not
hiding behind you gotta put Hulk behind
cover I feel you on that but at the same
time like I'm looking at like the
Berserkers on XCOM like there are
characters that will like couldn't be
behind cover like the Hulk but at the
same time it's like but they have
characters like that NX com so I think
that's why there was just so much
pushback because there is a lot of
things where that kind of Realm doesn't
work with XCOM but at the same time I
feel like enough enough give and take it
could have worked obviously Spidey
behind the company I I just don't see
Iron Man you know I feel you I feel it
yeah
that's why I I'm more optimistic with
stuff we appreciate you yeah
I got I do got it I do gotta clown you a
little bit Lord I mean yeah it is it was
funny in the beginning when it was
really early days and we were thinking
about what even what even is
um a Marvel game you know I I knew for
sure and what Marvel wanted from us and
what we knew we wanted to make was a
tactical turn-based game but I don't
even know what that looks like right so
we weren't even sure we were making so
in the beginning like some of the ideas
we thought about was like okay it'll be
like a shield game and actually like
we'll drop in you know maybe Wolfie
drops in for a mission as a hero but
actually it's more like XCOM and they're
all like Shield agents or whatever right
and then I was interesting yeah but then
I was like what the hell am I talking
about like I want like I want the Hulk
and I want Scarlet Witch all my favorite
characters like um but I did we
considered making like a shield version
Gamers like you're just a bunch of
Shield agents and then cap would drop in
for like a mission or two as a hero and
things like that but um so in that way
it would have been traditional X call
and then those guys I see what you go
with that that would have been whack but
we like what you did
I I do think the way you guys designed
it because I I'm still a little hesitant
with the card thing but after you get I
think the early game is what got me
because it's like I I wasn't feeling the
connect but once you get a little bit
further and you get access to more
things you can replace cards then you
feel like you have a little bit more
control but at the beginning it was just
like oh I can't do nothing more okay
like I guess I'll end my turn
I mean look the thing was we we
definitely did not want to design a new
game right I mean it really is a huge
undertaking to say to make one style of
game like XCOM that's ended up being
successful which is awesome and it's
such an undertaking from an art
perspective from an engineering from a
design perspective like the art was
whenever we made art and XCOM it was
made because of the artists all
understood the rules we got to make
things a certain way and there's cover
and it's got to be right so to then say
let's go out and make a whole new game
and it's not like um
enough Shooters are incredibly difficult
as well right but it's just different
where you're like okay the mechanics if
we're going to change the mechanics and
we're going to have a whole new we've
got to invent all these new rules to
make a tactical turn-based game it's
such an undertaking we're like well how
does the Arts how should the artwork in
a second I have no idea until we get the
game done right and until the design is
done and then it's such a task and so we
were trying to think of when we were
thinking of like making a shield game it
was like how can we not throw out
everything we've done for 10 years yeah
but instead we just did we threw out
everything we've done we just said like
you know what the game is best as this
thing yeah that means that like
all this success we built all this Tech
all this art knowledge we built up we
were like man just throw it outside so I
bet you that was a very nerve-wracking
thing like very nervous very
nerve-wracking very nerved especially
when you saw the Avengers game fail
right so that game fails uh well it does
let's not say fail that game doesn't
reach the lofty goals that was placed in
front of it right so you guys are coming
after that and do you feel like the the
pressure that okay so this is the Marvel
game that has to live up to the the
previous games mistakes
um did you feel that extra pressure that
this has to be the one that succeeds I
think that we had this this um roller
coaster of
so Marvel games
I mean I think I think I pitched this to
take to in early 20s before a war of the
chosen came out to like maybe spring
2017. when my work was wrapping up on
one of the shows and I was like okay you
know I need to pitch this to take two as
a publisher it's like Marvel wanted to
partner with us but I still had to
convince take two our ultimate publisher
of like why do you want to invest and
they had very smart questions fair
questions about like wait a minute
you've been building up xcompass
franchise we've invested all this money
there's this audience for it like now
you're going to tell me you're going to
do something you're going to take a
leftover like explain to us and again
take two is awesome they didn't for they
never forced me to do anything but it
was a case of like explain to us the
business reason for taking it yeah right
no that makes sense I'm sorry so I think
when we did that I think didn't
Spider-Man come out in Fall of
2017.18 2018. okay so it was a case of
there wasn't like a a huge record of
Marvel game success right right when we
had made this deal and so it was like
yeah sure the movies are really popular
I mean hardcore like I don't care I mean
I do like the movies but I'm a hardcore
Comics guy but like the movies were
super popular but there wasn't a huge
track record of gaming success correct
correct and so at least in the premium
the Triple A Space and so
he was like I don't know and then
Spider-Man came out and and Spider-Man's
one of the best games made in the last
years and so I played that and I was
like oh my gosh I was like I'm
intimidated
it was cool to see and you were like
okay cool we're part of this now
um and then Avengers maybe it you know
maybe that didn't reach what they wanted
with it and so then it was a little
jarring because you're like Avengers was
tricky because even when the game was
like there was like a cloud one even
when it was announced right like why are
people not reacting to this I was
surprised by it and so you're kind of
like oh Marvel's not like a you know
Marvel's no golden ticket right right
because it is and as maintenance the
people aren't it's still you still got
to make a great game right but it would
have been nice if you know Avengers came
out and then so like that sold twice
what Spider-Man did she like oh good
we'll just sell twice with events
Marvel was a golden ticket right so it's
a good point
that definitely for our team it was like
oh geez like the like the Marvel fandom
is like any fandom where it's like okay
you gotta prove you know what you're
talking about you get approved and what
I've said to them
other developers and Publishers my
experience with midnight Suns is that so
I'm again I'm you know I'm very very
hardcore Marvel and Rocco is also very
very hardcore Marvel we like soccer yeah
but you can't I don't think you can make
a game without being extremely
passionate about the IP yes because it
you really have to know the IP in and
out and like you have to really like
know it as well as the people you're
partnering with to wear if you want to
make a Lord of the Rings game you want
to make a game about whatever IP it is
Star Wars reversed in that thing you
have to like know it more than you have
to be the the sweaty guy to convince
being like I get you know on page 34 of
episode
with me yes
the color of his suit changes
I get so tired when you have these like
Publishers and even movies where like
they make these the TV shows movies
games and you could just fill like the
they didn't care about the gamer they
only cared about trying to appeal to
this big audience and the audience don't
care about what they move your game is
and The Gamers like yeah
I'm talking about the Halo trucks
respecting The Source material
it is very true like having a Passion
having a deep passion for something like
that you cannot you cannot fake it you
really cannot fake it and it's the kind
of thing that you'll miss and there's a
million decisions that get made when
you're telling a story when you're
making a game and there are a million
ways to add value if you love a product
and be like you know who would be the
right character for this or they should
say this or they would never say that or
you know like if you miss all of those
million decisions like it's gonna show
in the final product and so I think you
really it's great to say like I like I
know that I wouldn't be able to make
um a Star Wars game for example because
I love Star Wars not like I love like
Marvel's like I've been reading Marvel
for decades like I'm a Chris Claremont
X-Men like
I will go very very very deep and it's
like it was always Chris Claremont
versus Arthur Adams oh and
I really appreciate the cliff Cliff
Claremont
um stuff uh did you like
um the hellfire club uh storyline was
what were you into that yeah so so for
me when I first started reading
um X-Men it was when they were like in
Australia like like so I was like so to
me I started reading in like the late
80s 80s early 90s and it was
and so also a New Mutants guy which also
Chris Claremont right so like and so and
that's why like certain characters like
magic is in is yeah I can tell you had a
hand on that oh man I can tell you had a
hand on that one there was never any
doubt about magic being and so it's
funny because we had uh original my
original roster for the games like 25
characters and and storm was on the
original roster of the base game but it
was the kind of thing when we started
trimming it down I was like yeah some of
these characters like um uh The Punisher
was on the um on the base game roster
but I was like well the Punisher and
blade for me were too similar not in
terms of who they are but their
mechanics like a gun based gun-based
dude yeah
they would have felt like they would to
share the screen too much yeah yeah and
I wanted blade to be the like stoic like
I'm the New York gun stoic cool guy and
I was like there's actually not enough
air for like
um Frank Eve here right if I put Frank
in the game there wouldn't be enough
room for him to breathe because blade
already and blade weight made obviously
Blade was obviously going to be in the
game Punisher was in fact we um our
first playable prototype of the game
this is true our first place
um and there's video of it you know
somewhere in France or the three
characters were um Captain America storm
and Punisher
and and both storm got pushed to DLC and
Punisher I just said like this doesn't
make sense he steps on blades toes too
much but like Frank is one of my
favorite I really want to play character
storm is one of my favorite characters
so there were characters that I loved
that store I pushed the DLC and Frank I
just pushed out of the game but like
Frank one of my top five characters like
I didn't Punisher guy right and so
and you know I know you got to be
careful about saying that nowadays you
know you know I don't I don't have like
a Punisher sticker on my truck
like what you like man that's it
like that you went with Robbie Reyes
Ghost Rider yeah current you know um
yeah and he still paying all my choices
you know Robbie rules and and um we have
yeah Johnny's in the game obviously and
it's funny because Rocco loved Danny
catch ghost rider me too yeah well but
that's the that's when we grew up
reading right it's like Danny but um I
love Johnny because I think he has the
coolest you know like he's the cool
story and everything yeah hold on I
gotta wrote you Jake shout out to Lord
ACG in the chat he said damn patch is so
good I have a punch to stick on my truck
what I'd say is I am a white guy with a
lifted black like truck like my trucker
like a lifted F-150
stick on my truck and people are gonna
be like okay
so my daughters know how much I love
frank and and um so they bought me light
for my her daddy's their birthday
whatever they buy me Marvel stuff and
they bought me like a Punisher like this
is supposed to be stuck on your truck oh
thanks girls and I was like um
truck people will be like okay I know
what that dude's on yo
making good points about the characters
trusting the IP all that stuff I do have
to clown you on one thing though yeah
all right I love this part but this this
part got critical this [__] got ripped a
little bit okay okay all right the
hilarity
of midnight Sons
having Heroes sliding your DMs the
hilarity of midnight Sons at the bathing
suit at the pool and I'm kicking it with
storms we both with our bathing suits
yeah the hilarity of Wolverine talking
to me we shirt listen we bought
so did you have like tell me that whole
I call it Marvel Tinder I I any anybody
on the team will tell you that is a
hundred percent
anybody on the team will tell you like
Jake was like maybe creepy about how
much he wanted did Marvel push back in
here did anybody push back so so look
again I the reason I say I'm an X-Men
guy is really important because the
X-Men always had pool scenes yeah X-Men
all we had the X-Men was thirsty ass
X-Men is thirsty thirsty thirsty that's
what I grew up reading and so for me
like the X-Men pool like the very first
that anybody on the team will tell you
like I told them like we are going to
have a pool people are gonna have
swimsuits and I gotta tell you like so
then to make characters not just they
have tactical suits
don't we have to make bathing suits
which means you have to make off like
that is a ton of work a lot of work and
so
Garth who is the EP on the project
I love Garth and but I told him we're
not playing any games
you're doing too much Jay
producers what producers will do is
they'll schedule that stuff at the end
of the project that we won't have time
your stuff could get cut and I said I
said we're not playing games I said you
put that in front of the Abbey outfits I
want bathing suits in front of stuff
that I know has to get made because
students and also if you guys like um be
um famous like Marvel Comics had
swimsuit conditions right so
um there are and I plea I encourage
people to go and Google Marvel swimsuits
there you go see it's Canada again you
want to talk thirsty
they don't know man I don't know they're
like storming that swimsuit of the year
with the Mohawk and uh
it's easy easy it's just good stuff but
I I used to buy the I used to I mean I
used to buy the swimsuits
if people want to go on a real journey
please Google uh Punisher
because he has
all he's wearing is a skull
if you go look in um in Deadpool's room
they ask um so we decorate each Year's
room and I told them like uh Deadpool's
room and he actually has posters from
the Marvel swimsuit
yeah
brother I love it I think it's hilarious
I think that I'm just curious the last
thing did they
you you implemented it but like you
didn't go all the way as far as a full
romance part so that party like that you
ain't Romancing no and and um two two
quick notes woke up before we leave the
pool because it's my it's very important
um I'm gonna give some um it never told
before stuff let's go is that um we
actually had uh bikinis
um so right now we have an athletic cut
swimsuit athletic cut and we have the
one piece yes yes we actually had
triangle bikinis and we had we had just
briefs for the guys wow right so they're
actually were there were actually free
swimsuits
championships
I will tell you I will tell you like and
Tim's saying who was the Marvel
attractive he's amazing but um once we
actually got them in there it's like he
was like look no money
but he was like he was like drawing like
he was like these are really like
when you tell the artist then they're
like I need you to draw this and they're
like No One's Gonna know I drew it right
right
the funny thing was it was and I
actually get where Marvel was coming
from because I said like look
everybody's got to wear this and they're
like okay they're like but Doctor
Strange in like really small like
they're like they're like oh yeah Tony
Stark would wear small braids they're
like that's fine right even Captain
America maybe but doctor strange and
Tiny briefs like is a little out of
character
so we actually pulled um we actually
pulled the uh the the triangle bikini
and the um the briefs
actually oh so we had to pull those off
okay absolute salute to you for fighting
yeah the other thing that didn't ship
with the games I really wanted I really
sound like a pervert let's go
the game was supposed to have showers
right
let's go
in the dorm room they were supposed to
be like communal showers where like
sometimes the characters would be
hanging out just in towels that's true
then it's true there's a hundred percent
true
wow anybody anybody on the team could
it was one where
one where it was like he was like dude
what are we doing
okay okay oh my God I got to shut you
down
I'm gonna tell you if if it isn't in
this day and age and we were doing this
in the 90s bro we got that out
I just loved it he really went for it
though like he got a really shoddy shot
I thank you I appreciate it I love it
because I knew you was having fun with
it you know what I knew it was the
camera angles you was having by the pool
and the conversation I'm like someone's
having too much fun and I'm all about
this I was like this is hilarity and
it's fighting out you're good I will say
it's at least you didn't make that
because I'm not the side contact kind of
stuff it's like I ain't trying to be at
the pool side like where's the next
fight no it's great and salute to you I
think the Abbey is amazing it's kind of
three games in one to me you know you
got the strategy there you got the base
layer the tactics are amazing quick
question was the engine different from
because I feel like the combat
Battlefield Graphics is way better there
versus The Abbey a little bit Yeah is
there a different engine it's on a
different engine but it's just that um I
think it's a case of we spent so much
like we really focused so much on
tactical that like it's just strategy
just gonna didn't get nearly as much as
much love yeah yeah because I saw the
graphical the cinematics when they're
doing the powers and the combo stuff is
absolutely amazing so absolutely on that
yeah that was heavily heavily influenced
by like
um a lot of anime influence like uh
you'll see a lot of like there's a lot
like time dilation there's a lot of like
pauses and all these like really
powerful so yeah the our animation
director is really influenced by like
really powerful like anime and stuff
like that so now you killed their
brother you killed it I'm sorry I do
have one question
um
because I remember there was a time
where they were asking uh when the
rabbits Mario rabbits got announced
um you know obviously that went to
Ubisoft was there ever like if you could
pick on this this is you obviously but
if you could pick one IP in the industry
to make into a turn-based style type of
game what would that have been oh man so
not Marvel
because that obviously was my choice and
I got blessed like that what would I
choose
oh I mean so here's the thing is and I
actually talked to the Marvel guys about
this like
um
so I also really like Comics first right
I actually really like the boys right so
yeah
here's the thing is and I love the the
comics right Garth Ennis is this amazing
writer um Comics is crazy but here's
here's the problem with that is that why
I also feel like I could never make like
as much as I love frank The Punisher
like I could never make a Punisher game
because it's a little bit of the same
problem is that
when Frank is at his best is when he
goes too far right yes where he leaves
you behind where you you're with him
he's like yes this is a good Quest Frank
has always dealt with the but he's
written the best when it's like he's
yeah sure he's he's out there he's
protect the little guys protecting
people but Frank always goes too far and
he leaves you behind where you go like
whoa like that's too much and the
problem is to make a game to really tell
Frank's story and I feel like they kind
of did this I didn't love the show
because they kept trying to make Frank
too like relatable and I'm like
sympathetic it's not related Frank is
like he goes too you should at the end
of you should be like ah man like
but that's why I like war zone opposed
to the show yeah the the movie War Zone
I thought yeah yeah yeah it was perfect
for Frank yes and so the boys is the
best when it goes too far and I'm like I
could never make the boys because to be
true to the spirit of what that is yeah
and if I was to make a Punisher video
game it'd be like I'd have to take
players to a place where it's not it's
just not not it's not enjoyable it's not
nice you have to do things to really be
honest to the character right you have
to do things where you'd be like I don't
feel good you're like I think the boys
is the same thing it's it's fun to watch
that stuff or read that stuff but you
don't want to a game is a is a is where
you have agency and you're actually it's
interactive and I think
if the punisher's done wrong done right
it goes too far and you'd be like oh
actually this game's actually making
good stuff a lot of people feel bad
about you know a lot of people think the
TV show of of the boys is going too far
and it does push the envelope but the
books like heroism is crazy
I feel more people are talking about
where they think it's going too far but
it's just like that's why they this is
not for little kids for adults it's not
the books I always told my team I said
like look I said I genuinely do not even
though the boys is I do love it because
I love Darkness I loved reading it I was
like I am being honest here I do not
recommend people read it because it is
the show is nothing compared the books
are wow they're Wild Man a lot of real
stuff real stuff so a couple more
questions towards to get the end um I do
have to ask you as far as magic moment
you know obviously worked on rebooting
that's calm and then obviously you get a
chance to do your dream project so
what do you consider your magic moment
so far as a game developer
[Music]
um
I would I would say
like my I mean I have a couple like
really stand out moments I think
um
more that shows and felt great when when
I shipped that game I felt done I'm glad
that midnight Sons came along because
one of the shows kind of closed the book
on XCOM for me where I felt like
if somebody's gonna do something
Masterpiece it's a masterpiece I
appreciate that I mean I think I feel
like
you get to a point and it would be fun
to continue down that road but
you feel like
once you've once you've done it you're
kind of like I don't know where where to
go next where to go next my ideas would
probably not be true to XCOM because I'd
be like well I already did my bet I did
what I I thought were my my best ideas
and so we're the chosen um midnight Sons
for me being a huge Marvel it's actually
it's been tough for me
um like movies come out and Comics come
out and it's funny because for like five
and a half years I was part like it was
something else to be part Marvel you
know like it was real it made it as a
kid being like Oh I'm part of the Marvel
family and being able to no worries and
be in a position where I could say no
you know Rocco and I maybe some of my
best moments again Rocco the best
moments where he and I would be up
super late and we'd have these like
crazy like all these white boards
covered with like details of the story
and it'd be like we'll go here and then
we'll introduce this character and it
was magical as a kid who grew up reading
comics to be like we had access to it's
unlike Spider-Man or The Avengers game
like we were we're called the universe
title where we have access to every
single character in the universe and
that's almost overwhelming because
you're like we could put anybody in like
we could have collect this show up if we
want like we could do whatever we wanted
right and so for rock and I we were like
oh my gosh
the best nights we would just sit there
and be like oh my God what if this
happened what if that happened and so
those were also some of like my favorite
memories I think
just just having those moments you know
I don't know I have a lot of great
memories of for axis and I so been that
I gotta pick between your kids you know
you're you're revered what it chosen or
your dream project Marvel been nice
since you gotta pick which what is the
peak
maybe the proudest of because
I get it it's tough because you're doing
your dream and you got the thing now I
do got to ask the tough questions now we
got to get to the tough part okay so
obviously the midnight Sons
critically good reviews over 80 meta
critic very solid not as much financial
success
so you know obviously I think the CEO
okay now take two he talked about the
December release date maybe conflicting
with Callisto protocol high in life
around the same time you know then the
game gets discounted you know you leave
so I the two questions I have is like
okay
why do you think it underperformed and
then the second thing is like do you
because again we didn't know about your
departure at the time what was going on
so you know do you think it was burned
out or you had to die on your sword
because the game ain't do what it was
supposed to do yeah so now it's like all
right you know let me take this for the
team kind of thing because again no one
knew what happened and we know the the
the the the reviews were strong but the
financial part wasn't
yeah I mean I what I would say is that I
would imagine and I don't know obviously
I don't have I'm not proving this
information anymore I would imagine
midnight Sons will eventually be as
successful because again I'm doing this
I'm doing my part yeah I appreciate that
and and but those games they we have
what we our games Frank seems to be like
a long tail we call it just sell and
sell and sell and sell for years so I
would say XCOM was like that too yeah
that's almost like that too
um I think that for me so and you know
it's funny because nobody's ever
generally asked me about my my leaving
um
but my leaving was
um it was 100 a decision by me to do it
like it wasn't at all like there was no
pressure you know I I feel confident
that um like I was close with to KR
publisher and Frank said how come and I
could have done whatever I wanted to
going forward I was still in that
position but I just felt
um like it was just one of those times
where I had a new I had something I
wanted to do I just sort of dream of
what I wanted to do
um and I'd known I was going to leave
probably for three or four months before
I did before I even announced it towards
the end has been that sense I was
already thinking like okay I'm Gonna
Leave You know Garth my EP he also left
right so of course right
um and so we both kind of knew we were
leaving
because we did XCOM together he and I
done XCOM together we did night sons and
then the idea of even if we did another
Midnight Sun so we did it whatever it is
I just felt I just did not feel that
like I I'm a very
obsessed obsessive type of personality
and when I started thinking about like
okay
we're going to do something next and do
something new as much as I loved Marvel
as much as I love turn based
I just didn't I just didn't feel free
passion right I got you okay and so I
thought man this is not
if I if I do this like I just felt like
it'd be risky for me to do it like it
requires so much like making a game in
my position requires so much time the
only way you can put in that much time
is that like you go to bed thinking
about you wake up think about you're
just so passionate and I just was not
feeling that anymore and so I do have
something new I'm passionate about and
it just caught like once it once it
takes hold of your brain I just realized
like this is not a game I would make it
it's not a game that's that I would make
at Francis and so I was like this
probably means I should leave okay well
that's fair you know and it's tough I
mean again I'd worked there 23 years I
love I love the place I love the people
I love the games we made there
I would never like leaving for me was
never like oh this is awesome I'm
leaving and I'm excited to do my own
thing it really was more a case of like
I just feel like I have to like I really
want to make this new game I keep making
it for anxious it doesn't make sense
like I gotta leave no and it makes sense
again if it's a departure from turn base
and based on the studio history most
likely it's not going to be something
that's going to be green lit based on
because this is the house of
civilization and that's common tactics
and so I get that part you know I was
surprised to be honest it's that maybe
not your decision but I was surprised
that the switch version wasn't was
canceled because I felt it would have
been a great home for the switch and to
get more sales for poor so I was shocked
that you know I don't know 2K or
whatever didn't go there
um so that that was the only thing but
I'm glad you said that because I was
curious and I was like damn I don't
reinforce my man out of the building
this is you this is you no I I think
they were and in fact they were really
really awesome when it was 100 my
decision leaving me the hardest thing I
had to do was tell Sid that I was
leaving because I oh I really owe him
everything and he was oh gee he was
awesome to me like he he had multiple
company meetings and they gave me a
party to leave on so it was all very
very it was very positive dope was kind
of the thing where I was like I've been
there a long time I'm sure some people
are like oh finally
you know
damn bathing suits
that's right that's right there so yeah
midnight Sons too I know why I know why
man if there aren't bathing suits I will
flip out
no it was a very it was a very positive
I mean it was it was sad because I love
the place and I think they have love for
me too and
um but it was it 100 it was well well in
the works before yeah midnight sons was
even close to coming out I had already
shared with them like I said look I I
think this is it
I feel bad no salute to you you know
doing chasing your dreams you had a you
know beautiful exit speech you know I
love what you said you thanked everybody
you know the 2K to everyone at foraxis
and then you kind of leave it where I
say I love designing tactical turn-based
games but it's time for another time for
other smarter people to push that space
forward my brain is on fire with a new
dream time to go chase it and um this is
where we are now which is a final
question which is um you know we're
hearing rumors you know life Sims and
maybe things of that nature and try to
get another turn-based page you know
talk about this this change and like why
this specific pivot As you move on into
this next chapter for yourself
I think
there yeah it just is the kind of thing
that took hold and my original love even
even going back to when you think of the
original
XCOM like that was much more of a
simulation than the game that I ended up
designing which was much more of a I I
would say much more of a board my style
as a designer when making x-com and even
midnight Sons is very much like a very
clear like more board game which is very
clear like choices are almost binary
where it's like you do this and you get
that and
um whereas opposed to I grew up playing
games that are simulation style games
and I always leaned away from that but
I'm really really passionate I see the
opportunity for and maybe what I
not what I missed but on on midnight
Suns what didn't happen as much was the
um the storytelling aspect of XCOM that
comes out of where the play I think the
most powerful stories are the ones the
player creates in their head yeah when
they get a soldier and they get a
nickname and they get a country right
that's all you need is like they're from
this country thanks got this nickname
once they level up and uh this is their
Soldier class and it's like now I know
all of a sudden you start writing these
stories and they form bonds with this
Soldier and they save the team this day
or they they died heroically and those
things I really I want to explore more
of that where players like
players get to create players get to
create story players get to create
um content just by playing a game like I
want to go back to that and I kind of
want to explore that more and I think
Sims games that are like actual
simulations
um like so I played rimworld and tour
Fortress and The Sims like those games
you end up writing stories you end up
creating your own stories and um I think
that's the space I'm really excited
about that will salute to you man we
wish you the best of luck on your next
chapter the absolute Legend he gave us
more time that I even thought I would
get you know Jake's I appreciate this so
much so much for having me we appreciate
you
um we have to we have a tradition here
that we do on the exit which was um we
asked to we need your top five video
games or franchises of all time let's go
Scott with that foreign
specific one if that makes it easier all
right I will say I will say
um UFO defense
gets his flowers let's go Julia Gallop
let's go there's no questions I would
actually say Minecraft would be one of
my top five games Xbox you hear you hear
this I love I love I love Minecraft and
it it's had a second win for me playing
with my daughters just like open my eyes
up to it as well so I put Minecraft up
there I would have to say the ultimate
games right so those are the first games
that really affected me absolutely so I
would also say GTA so I am I've beaten
every GTA since Vice City like I don't
beat a lot of games but like I love GTA
right so first GTA reference here in a
room yeah yeah yeah uh I'd say GTA and
then
um
I think the last one I beat was The
Ballad of Gay Tony I remember oh my gosh
Jake and King need a comic book podcast
um let's see all right so what am I at
four I got four yeah four oh man this is
tough to choose a final favorite
um it's not going to be a Marvel project
no no all right okay so this is so tough
right any game we know this is so tough
to do one game that actually whether
it's it was maybe a top five experience
for me oddly enough it was a game called
Fable Fable 2 right
is he annoying annoyed now addict is
faithful all right you see attic smile
too
why Fable too
um so Fable 2 I loved it and it's
actually it's funny this is what games
are for you right I remember Fable 2
came out right after my dog passed away
and Fable too gives you a dog and I
remember that like that for me was like
it was just so affecting for me like I
played that game and my wife she Jenny
would sit down there and just watch me
play and I just I love Peter molyneux is
like I've played his games forever right
populist and and oh yeah black and white
and um
um so yeah Fable II I would put up there
as one of my top experiences
Cosa and last one favorite console of
all time and why
yeah I'm marking more
[Laughter]
Sega CD bring those memories
I mean I didn't I didn't rep it well but
I would say you know I would say yeah do
I do I say Dreamcast or do I say I think
I I think I would say I would say Sega
Genesis for me like
Genesis would be my my pick because I
had Nintendo but like Sega I just
remember a lot of my memories man he was
being bit baby 16 bit that's the 16th
crap
they do with Nintendo
[Applause]
this is why he's the goat ladies and
gentlemen the legendary Jake Solomon the
commander to us all at XCOM rebooted the
franchises I mean look I just got to be
honest with you man you you are the
reason I really gave turn-based games a
shot to be honest you know Enemy Unknown
Enemy Within transformative games being
played for hours apart hours the story
is self-contained that you tell and then
to go to Midnight Sun something
gradually different but to utilize the
car system to get the personality of the
heroes and it's just such an addicting
game in the loop we're looking forward
to the next chapter of your journey
going to support you an absolute Legend
addict King I want everybody to get
their bars off to the legend before he
goes Lord attic any final words to say
to Lord Jake Solomon on his way out
I appreciate you coming on you know one
of the biggest squats that I want to
highlight that you said is that when you
made that first prototype you took your
ego out of it and you were saying I'm
not making a game for me I'm making a
game for people and and it takes a lot
to do that a lot of people can't do that
actually so uh you know thank you for
coming on and giving us your story Lord
solve I appreciate you suffering through
this interview
listen tell the truth I have ingrained
issues with micro Pros I have no I know
issues with you oh oh you got you got
beef I'm gonna get Jake I'm gonna get
Julie though Jake Jake remade
Julia's back pool because um he reached
out to us when we he had dropped a
phoenix point we could get you yeah yeah
but that that's all it's just you know
old trauma that's fine I will say this
though in listening uh a lot of stuff
that you like and and have made is in
some ways adjacent to immersive Sim so I
wonder if what you're trying to what
you're going towards maybe touches upon
that because it kind of opens up the
possibilities doesn't constrain you to
like a grid or anything like that or a
set of rules yeah are you looking at
something like that possibly within
whatever you mean like something like uh
System Shock or Dishonored or something
right but taking that to a another level
yeah I mean no I think I'm still like I
I love those games and it's funny so
Harvey
um who you know designed Dishonored the
funny thing about that is it Dishonored
and XCOM Any Man known came out on the
same day oh October 9th 2012 both games
so we were always like linked together
interview Harvey
yeah yeah he's awesome he's very very
smart very awesome guy
um did he just do red four yeah we're
gonna move on
you're gonna be nice today
though the legend
Ary yeah I do I do like let's talk about
you okay
you're adding stuff like that
yeah I like immersive Sims but I don't
yeah no that's that's I think my I'm
still I'm still in the the uh the the
other categories okay no doubt Lord King
any final words for your newly found
comic book brother yo it's more than
that um from the moment that I I came on
the show because a lot of people I know
y'all hear about it I come in with music
right and um I came in with the music
and today I I was playing uh Jay-Z's the
Takeover facts
um and immediately
Jake knew like he's like oh yeah and
um from there to to the boxing uh to the
comic books to the x-com uh to what your
future endeavors are
and and your support system
um you're able to be that versatile and
remove that ego out of yourself because
you remove the ego out of yourself even
when you was talking about your wife
being supportive yeah right a lot of a
lot of guys want to oh no no I'm the man
of the house no no yes I know who the
boss is right so right there you you
already are in that humble state where
you understand uh how a team works yeah
and when when you left the project and
you had to come back to the project
because nobody wanted to actually grow
the project they wanted to go exactly
from your words and you got things like
now let's take that out this doesn't
work
um that's a team player 100 a team play
so so I truly appreciate you showing up
today I knew this was really cog's day
because he's been you're his Moby Dick
pause like
his great white will trying to to get
this guy in and I'm Remembered in the
chat because he put it in the chat when
you follow back and you were coming on
and I was like oh man this is gonna be a
good one and I thought it was gonna be a
good one for him it was more a good one
for me yeah yeah to be honest you talk
about Dr Doom Dr Doom is my favorite
villain and and for you to say
he's not just a villain yeah you went
into the psychia Doom yeah and even to
know that every year that he goes down
and fight all the demons in hell to get
to sit down with his arms
is incredible so to have you on I
appreciate you so much trust me thank
you and I know that you're going to do
fantastic in your next Endeavor because
you are removed from one contracted to
the next contractor you'll be getting
that boat soon sir that's right yeah
next time I come on it's on my boat all
right bro we're gonna do the podcast on
the boat that's how we do it listen man
what if I gave it Heroes The Legend you
know again thank you so much for the
time you gave us lots of so much more
time and uh it's a story of perseverance
and and checking ego and pride and
knowing you know what I need to go back
into dojo and I love that you got the
co-sign from Julian as well that was
super special because obviously he
helped inspire you but again brother
thank you so much enjoy your day have a
good one the legend thank you Jake
Solomon thank you guys all right have a
good one brother
no doubt good old stuff good stuff um
let's get the super chance off or you
want me to get I got a couple and then
there's no Ken got some stuff he got to
do okay so when I'm gonna do my stuff is
it gonna be after the Super chats yeah
whatever you want whenever you want okay
you let me know all right so I can get
myself
I'm copy pasting a couple seconds all
right so I'll do the poll then I'll do
the poll all right last week poll
results are into the question with the
extremely positive reception for Zelda
tears of the kingdom do you feel
Nintendo gets a pass for performance in
their AAA titles the winner of the
three-way IOP poll at 56 56 percent of
the vote was the switch is not held to
the same performance standard with
review scores as their competitors group
wow coming in there it can't compete
like
oh yeah
you saw
coming in at second place at 31 of the
vote was switches older Hardware never
touted power and the quality of the game
is Paramount Group oh my goodness
wow logic and it didn't win and it did
not win
everybody cared about the ugly baby why
why can't I run Angry Birds on this
Blackberry wow and in last place at 12
on the vote was I don't care I thought
we was boycotting 30 FPS group shout out
to all the lawyers has a lot to say so
let's get the the realm does not agree
with yourself yeah I don't care yeah I
always y'all always in the clouds boy
let me go to the bathroom all right so
okay
we usually it's funny we usually don't
get a lot of super chats while that was
a good energy while into what like while
a guest is here right we got a lot yeah
we got a decent amount yeah
okay we had
a zgl7 remember for nine month Lord hold
the line I think I read that one though
um then you you read valicons already
yeah oh actually we have oh Jericho new
member Lord go put the crust in the chat
for Lords
and valicon five dollars we can tell you
guys are killing it keep up the great
work I am very proud of you all shout
out to faraxes for the midnight Sons
loving this stuff oh somebody just
copped that hold the line t-shirt and
white let's get it yeah King's cameras
off I'm sure that has something to do
with it oh no go get the general then we
got Dragonheart you'll remember for one
year five dollars so we tap my favorite
game from SNES it was called super
Boogerman that was my design I have to
go to bathroom Boogerman was good
actually
he threw boogers at his enemies and he
farts on them too I need a remaster
Savage
there we have Matt without fear 10
pounds if we chat member for one year
wasn't sure I'd like the turn-based
gameplay of midnight Suns but after uh
trialing it on a free Xbox trial I
immediately bought the legendary edition
thanks for such a great fun game hashtag
was right oh absolutely absolutely I
appreciate that giving it a shot man
give it my shot there we got zip Davis
five dollar Super Chat I'm with Sackboy
we are holding the line together
whoa whoa you switch sides after being
forced to QA dreams it's okay sagging
nut sack but it's okay sagging nut sack
about me Jesus
then we got Dean Rivera five dollar
Super Chat my 16 year old dog passed
Friday night in my arms heading to the
hospital it hurts but watching y'all
talk games helps the grief Hold the Line
condolences
then we have nintendog the otaku new
member five dollar Super Chat XCOM Enemy
Unknown got me into everything strategy
I was put off by the games like Fire
Emblem my other games like Fire Emblem
and now it's one of my favorite
franchises thanks to it yeah absolute
Nintendo Taco again five dollar Super
Chat I need someone to ask an important
question what's the real percentage when
you have a 95 chance to hit because I
definitely missed more than five percent
of the time you should have asked that I
was just thinking about it too the
conversation was so good it was so good
I didn't want to keep stopping them yeah
I was like yeah that's an interesting
conversation unto itself just the
numbers game behind that stuff because
that's yeah that's wow uh let me see
Dragonheart Yobe remember for one year
five dollar Super Chat please let us
know if there's a sequel coming the
ending credit scene was everything
Marvel midnight Sons is a classic and my
first RTS game ever because he's gonna
come out there and say yeah there's a
Marvel
it ain't it ain't his baby that's for
sure somebody else's baby then we have
acute perspective remember for six
months two dollars to chat what
intrigued him and making midnight Sons
card base you got that hand you got that
answer then we got David hot right
remember for one year ten dollars that
I'm running 15 minutes behind since I
started the stream late but I had to say
that Jake's thoughts on uh Ari Pride
were so true and they really hit
appreciate all the work happy Lords day
that's right no doubt
pride is your enemy Dragonheart you'll
be member for one year five dollars for
chat my bad I meant to say tactical RPG
midnight Sons too please
Robert Kelly Jake preaching about a new
layer to Dr Doom oh yeah he was in his
doctor doing bad that's that's a that's
a fan man a fan understands the psyche
of the character and I'm glad that he
was on that project because a lot of the
things that the characters wouldn't do
uh and I know he held the line on that
he was just like nah blade wouldn't do
that oh oh you know Captain Marvel
wouldn't say that you know so facts
we're pretty much you know um are where
their character should be
and we got
um Spartan go 17 a five pound Super Chat
Jonathan Hackman Fantastic Four has my
favorite version of Doom also there's a
Luke Cage comic where he is chasing Doom
down because he owed him 50 bucks he
hired him to go uh fight the Fantastic
Four and Luke Cage one of his fifty
dollars I found that to be Riley one of
the most racist books going but I found
it to be one of the most funniest books
that's crazy and we got Dragonheart Yogi
again uh I remember for one year five
that's the chat
also the main character can possibly
span out into their own comic series I
would I would so read that and make it
happen Marvel unlimited yeah the main
character is called the Hunter right
yeah I doubt it because the hunter is
crafted by whoever by whoever's playing
yeah
the angry therapist MD five dollar Super
Chat I love this man he gets doomed No
Doubt
we got Lord valicon two dollars of a
chat why is Wolverine six feet tall
yeah right tell the truth ain't the
devil
here we got Joe Repco AKA flame member
for 31 months Lord bronze good afternoon
IOP I could be cheering about the EU
smacking the taste out of the cma's
mouth but instead I'll tell everyone to
watch lognet tomorrow
look out for lagnet tomorrow if you
already know and we got Dragonheart Yogi
again remember for one year five dollar
Super Chat a spin-off Mass Effect game
made by faraxis that would be fine that
would be awesome no doubt then we got
Reggie mobile9 member for 25 months Lord
bronze all right great show and awesome
interview salute to the best gaming pod
in the game thank you brother absolute
Dragon heart yobi once again two dollars
for the chat also midnight Sons got me
in my feelings oh emotional it's a
little
then we got the Macho channel two dollar
Super Chat homie it all makes sense now
has that Marvel pool party
look he fought for that he fought for
that son
let's play with each other's joysticks
[Applause]
I need to see sovereign
let's go
that was dude that was crazy
towels
unisex showers
so wait The Hub was the X the X mansion
or was it someplace it's called The
Abbey yeah okay all right then we got r
b AKA underground gamer five dollar
Super Chat please ask what was the
reasoning for changing the Marvel comic
title for midnight Suns would it
wouldn't o to midnight Sons with a u
much love to the IOP team he gets there
sends their regards I didn't get a
chance to answer that one you know
uh then we got Robert Kelly again two
dollar Super Chat because in the comic
books they're called the midnight Sons
with a u with the nice Sons with an o oh
okay okay that's that's actually a title
oh okay so that's accurate okay then
Robert Kelly Super Chat you really loved
Dead or Alive huh Jake
you know which one he likes what was it
um
beach volleyball oh yes amazing graphics
and we have tiny casara's fifteen
dollars we chat I want to know where
Jake is hiding that midnight Sun's
coffee edition if you know what I mean
thank you Jake for making one of the
best games of all time x-com and thank
you Lords for a great show nice
appreciate it brother Reggie mobile9
once again remember for two years five
dollar Super Chat Applause great show as
always great as always Lords one of your
best interviews absolutely thank you
then we got Robert kellett five dollar
Super Chat so what do we do General King
when Sony drops bombs like the Konami
exclusives GTA 6 marketing deal and
that's Spider-Man how do we hold the
line by holding it who the hell tell you
to run don't run or you could be like
the other cowards that turns hell and
ran but don't come back when the fool
getting good hunker down and hold the
line there you go
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
then we got Robert Kelly
he would love tears of the Kingdom
probably would probably no he won't if
it's played on a sting deck
get that resolution up baby then we got
Matt Jimenez member for six months
welcome Lord Gore put the Crescent in
Chapel Lord gold let me make sure he
didn't say no he didn't say oh cool okay
then we got the list 22 member for 27
months Lord bronze we're going to 7 P.M
fam now we not remember that Jesus
but never did war The Chosen this
interview tells me I need to rectify it
oh you ain't do water he's playing that
damn division got your mind walk man
and you play Aaron you didn't play water
then we got Robert Kelly Two Dollars
Super Chat I don't know what king says
my ugly baby it's beautiful to me as it
is
Paris love their ugly babies
Hey listen um cataract training on
Tuesday
I gotta train your cataracts you gotta
make sure your cataracts is up to Snuff
any media Publications that has uh uh
has games of the service lit the Xbox
brand should not get review codes oh the
last attack
it's not game as a service any media
publication that is gas lit the Xbox
should not get review codes that's right
that's right no no no review coach
Sony they holding it oh man then we got
black Ronin three five seven five dollar
Super Chat that interview and his
answers sold me I'm picking up midnight
Sons half off so I can see the swimsuits
listen whatever reason you need to get
he gave you incentive Now
APK coming Xbox soon let's go
and we got Cameron Hill 20 Super Chat
Cog I wanted to stop in and show some
love appreciate our conversations on
Twitter also can you give the best
energy I think I've ever seen in this
industry love your passion man hold the
line we trending right now got kick out
here we got rap star Freddie Foxx
in the building red Falls FPS can and
will be improved not tears of the
kingdoms htl yes this is this is this is
facts tell the facts
and it's still going to be a 65. yeah
yeah yeah but we don't play numbers
our eyes though train your cataracts
Savage
[Music]
Targaryen ten dollars soon to chat uh
King I don't I don't got the money for
your uh champagne campaign the champagne
right now but Phil should come out with
the do-rag at the game awards if the
deal goes through with if I can't buy 57
wow
just walk past Sony playing Window
Shopper
messy
you owe me five dollars Super Chat let
me play with your joystick gonna pop up
wearing a thong and on the back it says
[Music]
what happened to peace love life what
happened today
that we got um face 23 bkny 20 Super
Chat what I'm excited to see at the
PlayStation showcase is games shown
running on PS5 and not PC Sony must be
really confident going ahead of everyone
else by like a week and a half yeah okay
nah it's not that it's just certain
stuff had to come out at this time they
all everybody's confident in their shows
you know but remember this year you only
get Spider-Man so sit down and wait
hold the line for Spider-Man
oh
anyways my boys I'm gonna kill it two
dollar Super Chat jokes on you King I
wear glasses
I know because you had your switches
since you got your switch you wear
glasses
training let's see and we got uh Tyson
Lewis remember for 18 months Lord Brian
King that line gonna be be thin if they
drop Blue Points bloodborne that's
that's true ain't nobody Karen if you
got a PlayStation ain't nobody selling
their Xbox and run out of go get it
we're gonna have new merch drop that day
talking about Retreat
ain't nobody running back and see that c
you talking to the Kool-Aid heart people
stop talking to Kool-Aid hot people I'm
done yeah we got Dragonheart yo we two
dollars and then he turns to Cognito
says my man oh gold this man made a
whole storyline about this
yeah that's why I gotta be a to be
continued continued bro crazy right
there
we are caught up yeah we're ready we're
ready all right all right guys here we
go support for iron Lord's podcast is
brought to you by manscaped who is the
best in men's below the waist grooming
their products are Precision engineered
for your family jewels manscape
performance package the ultimate men's
hygiene bundle join over 8 million men
worldwide who trust manscape with this
exclusive offer for you 20 off and free
worldwide shipping with the cold iron
Lord at manscapes.com if my math is
correct that's about 16 million balls
now you know
I ain't gonna lie wifey uh purchased me
my manscape probably a year ago for my
birthday right and I can tell you why
she did this
um you know we get those hair trimmers
right those big boba's hair trimmers
they're like and they're very scary when
you turn them on and I you know I go in
the bathroom and I'm trying to get you
know uh clean the package up because the
pack I'm looking like Harry and the
Hendersons right so I go down and I
clean it up but when I left I look like
the Toxic Avenger because I had patches
in my head
really didn't go well wifey known my
effort she tried and you know she went
out and got me to manscape so you know
right now I got the manscape of 4.0 and
it has Delight if I had this light and
you see how quiet it is and it has the
ceramic uh blade uh that helps you know
the skin safe technology
I'm confident so when I go down there
and I trim up my package my package is
looking you know pretty fine right now
you understand wifey loves it so let me
tell you man the performance package 4.0
has arrived and oh man is it a game
changer inside the package you'll find
the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
air and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant you need that because let
me tell you right now a lot of you dudes
they got to fix that situation crop
preservable deodorant with the cropped
Revival toner performance boxer brief
and a travel bag
this stuff is amazing the stuff that you
get to use with manscape is fantastic
and it'll boost your confidence in the
bedroom inside and out first off the
lawnmower 4.0 this trim is the future of
grooming and dare I say the greatest
ball trimmer ever
the fourth generation trimmer features
Cutting Edge ceramic blade that reduces
the The Grooming accidents that happens
oh sorry that reduces The Grooming
accidents thanks to their Advanced skins
take skin safe technology the lawnmower
4.0 is waterproof and also has a 4K
Spotlight you need for the more
Precision shave that's the spotlight
that I was showing you guys it
definitely works
because of this trimmer is waterproof
you can say goodbye to the mess in the
bathroom floor that's right listen guys
you can stand in the shower you can
handle your situation you don't have to
make a mess on the floor and the wife
doesn't have to come after you
all right the crop preserver ball
deodorant and crop Revival ball toner
will definitely change the way you
approach a hygiene routine trust me when
I say this fellas your balls will thank
you
get 20 off and free shipping with the
cold iron Lord at manscape.com that's 20
off with the free shipping at
manscape.com with the cold iron Lord
unlock your confidence and always use
the right tools for the job with
manscape
so I'm just gonna make sure everything
I'm gonna be all right so I guess you
use coal iron Lords I go to basket it's
iron Lord iron Lords with an S which one
is it iron Lord oh I Lord so I Am Lord
and then I'm gonna make sure everything
is right and this is the nose hair
trimmer I mean it this this stuff
I'm liking that buzz yeah
I have the whole package here they send
the whole package in
and you have the boxer briefs I mean
it's great stuff but the stuff that you
really need the most guys and I'm going
to tell you is the trimmer I mean the um
the the crop preserver and the ball
deodorant a lot of you dudes thinking
y'all out here you're dancing in the
mirror
hey y'all y'all want these situations to
go down nicely
please be considerate of the individual
you actually
situation
they go into the situation right yeah
man yo y'all put deodorant under your
underarms right because
you can't
you don't want me looking like a like
Tom Hanks and Cast Away oh man that's we
gotta make sure the packages had to
write care
y'all know what to do cold iron Lord
lakes in this in the description as well
as uh yeah just put it in the chat right
there make sure y'all go get that be
fresh and clean for the ground
we got a couple super chances
he said King's wife said I can see the
master sword now
yeah
man skate go to bedskate.com
been coming out here with them Dusty
Master sauce
isn't it decayed when you first get
tears in the Kingdom
[Laughter]
make sure y'all do that fellas let's go
Robert Kelly watch out for that joystick
in this man
I'm done
yeah we got the the otaku five dollar
Super Chat uh replay station Fanboys
seem to only be hyper remix God forbid
PlayStation actually makes some new
games this check
probably probably not the thing to say a
week out not a days out from when
they're gonna announce hey don't be weak
stand on your Square baby there you go
there we got Matt without fear five five
pounds Super Chat King put the Tremor
down we don't need any shopping channel
demonstrations
oh we thought you was gonna get a live
demonstration
you got it you gotta show the products
oh you you hold it a lot that's on the
patreon
if you go to the patreon right now you
can see Lord addict
you can see little attic masses on
situation you can see Lord addicts
[Laughter]
and that's the true tears of the Kingdom
we got appropriately sagging nut sack
two packs
game and I ain't never going back so now
you gotta go back with Cold Island it
gets you joint man
get that second 4.0 y'all can use that
code for all the additional products
that they do have there they have more
products to keep your situation
go get that man
I thought it was iron Lords with the S
all right so let's see you outside and
you you know you just you just ran a
full right you playing basketball right
and you just ran a full right you got to
crop my wipes in your pocket you know
what I'm saying just wipe it in between
clean that up and clean that up man
clean that up man you just you just
don't be running around here sticky
hickey
stay fresh
let me hit that because I think it's
iron low yeah just just double check we
gotta make sure yeah okay all right we
got the Liz twenty two five dollars
Sarah Bonds in the house bad new Sacha
in the house bad news Phil Spence in the
house bad news whenever Phil is around
it's bad news
trim the line and hold the sword oh
yeah
let's go here we got fawns
still the most entertaining podcast in
the community uh keep up the awesome
work gentlemen love Yeah salute my God
good to see you brother always loved
that's what I got right there
it's on me before we still got uh
patreon actually which was interesting
we got um sack shop much love too many
too many sacks today and manscape today
and balls and magic swords and oh my God
all right much love as always looks like
soft talk Sundays coming to an end then
I guess I need to go grab my uniform and
report to duty because we going to war
so I guess this is Hold the Line talk
for kids is that a question no it was
just a statement all right so don't
don't forgive me for this name jovar
jorvar jovar yeah Indie Harrelson all
right I have a question do you think all
first party Studios should be held to
the same standards I mean all Studios
should produce quality games but I'm
talking about the scale and Graphics
Studios like Bethesda and naughty dog
have over 400 employees while Studios
like obsidian have 200 and Ninja Theory
have 120 but some expect a vow to be as
large and impressive as Elder Scrolls
and hellblade 2 to match the Last of Us
games should fans expectations be
consistent or vary based on Studio size
it's our attic
I think um it just depends on the type
of quality they're gonna they're gonna
make they can make the type of quality
game that something like Bethesda has
maybe it's not going to be as big but
there's a lot of fluff that's in some of
these games so you cut some of that out
and it's all about the talent too uh not
every developer's uh created equal some
developers are going to be able to do
the workload that three or four people
can do because they're more
knowledgeable and have more experience
doing it no doubt Lord uh saw the king
thoughts on should expectations Studios
based on size
I mean in terms of scope yeah like Alex
said for sure
um in terms of scope absolutely right um
You Look At hellblade Hellboy looks like
a triple a game to and through how their
new hellblade actually and the first one
as well right what do they call it a
triple I back then yeah right so um but
it's not gonna be a you know it's not
gonna be a Last of Us two 35-hour game
it's not going to be that right it'll be
a it'll be a smaller game but if the
level of quality is there that's all
that matters I mean again everybody
should be held to the same standard when
it comes to releasing broken stuff and
just a level of Polish and quality
overall it's not you know scope is a
totally different thing and I don't
expect you know look at the outer worlds
as well right the outer worlds is is
kind of you know a smaller version of
what the Bethesda game studios games are
so um no no no absolutely but just the
quality bar and polish should be there
and that's it no doubt King your
thoughts on Studio size after you know
um talking with Jay I really honestly
believe that it has everything to do
with who's the lead uh guy in charge you
know a girl in charge uh Soul goes the
team so goes the the games because you
can have uh a game that is made by 20
people that looks like a triple A game
and a game that's made by 500 people and
it looks like a double a game so it
really has to do with the person that's
in charge in the vision that's there I
say do as much research on a game before
the game comes out and your expectations
will lead you in that way if we expected
a certain thing from a title and it
didn't live up to those expectations I
think you hold that studio accountable
but again when we have a studio that has
a smaller staff and those dudes exceed
our expectations do we Elevate them
right you know also again it all goes
into your research you know and and what
you see because what you may see from a
game and what somebody else may see from
a game is two different things so I say
you know do your own research and figure
out what game fits you before I answer
uh Lord solved Gerald Max said we missed
his super chat so if we could try
I did copy it yeah he said that he just
put it oh okay and then I met him up for
two years two dollars with that let's
talk approvals all hail the IOP salute
hashtag Hold the Line we about to get
today
we got you we got it now you're good
you're good so yeah no I agree I think
this is a very great question my jovar
um I think sometimes we do look at all
Studios the same when the size is
dramatically different I agree with King
though I think we should kind of really
Elevate the ones that punch above their
weight like I look like a Ninja Theory
with the first hellblade you could have
told me that was a big big squad team
and I would have thought otherwise it
really you know punched above his weight
there
um yeah it's interesting because you
don't you don't normally talk about
Studio size in relation to quality of
the game so yeah I think we need to be
more cognizant of it so I think it's a
good good point but that's why Matt we
got one more patreon we had a lot this
week um this is the last one Brian Lords
in anticipation for the upcoming
showcases from Sony and Xbox I find
myself reminiscing about previous
showcase experiences and announcements
one in particular being when Final
Fantasy VII remake was announced with
the trailer during PlayStation
experience I myself happen to be
watching the event in a movie theater in
the place went absolutely bananas my
question for you what if any game
announced remake or new would have you
jumping out of your chair with
excitement to clarify this would not be
your most anticipated game this is
something that comes out of left field
and has your jaw dropped
um from Microsoft it'll be rise too oh I
I I would probably lose it uh Tony yeah
um it will be uh the metal gear remake
that I've been dying for that I've been
wanting to see
I I really want that game and from
Nintendo it will be a New Wave Race
if they can just uh those
those three games from those three uh
developers I really would love to see
those games and I will go crazy for the
New Wave Race I will go crazy uh for the
new metal gear uh to get that experience
again with with today's graphics and and
the rise I mean because right still
holds his weight now I can imagine what
it would do cry attacking their bags
anybody else solve at it
um
there's a couple things Microsoft could
do I think giving me a
a an acquisition of missed Walker with
uh Lost Odyssey too
a full-blown faithful one remake I think
would be I would flip out on that I love
that they're you know doing Fable uh
going forward but I would love to see
like a reboot like Resident Evil 4 style
from the ground up with paper one I
think that would be a good thing
Sony
um you know just go ahead and buy Square
Enix so I can stop bitching
[Laughter]
don't say that and uh Nintendo
I wanna I wanna
I want another gotcha for us oh I really
like that game they haven't made one we
got 750 watching let's get those lights
buttons
share it out all right now we saving the
um Siberian koala
you know I love Siberia and we got to
save all those animals that's over there
but the Siberian koala is definitely in
danger we need to make sure
danger
the moment
anyway
imagine
like these animals just sitting there
looking at the light
I mean
Nintendo I would like love to see f-zero
come back
um on the Xbox side
I don't want to know anything
specifically from Xbox like first
parties I'll say Sega Sega Fantasy Star
coming oh as a straight-up Artist as an
RPG online
let's go and then PlayStation
I gotta say man I I would love them to
come back to either Killzone or um the
hell is the other one but do it
completely different out of the studio
though yeah no I mean Killzone the
Killzone guys are doing them
Whatchamacallit they're doing a horizon
I mean they they canceled that franchise
the franchise that they said yeah they
actually they actually just recently
shut down the page but something I don't
know just just go back to an old
franchise and change the story up
completely completely
um I would love to see that what the
hell is the other alien franchise that
they it was a long time they're going
with the gun I know what you're talking
about too
um that's the one we like uh who make
that sucker punch made that who who made
why can't I remember this damn game yeah
it begins with R it was the the Chimera
with the yeah with the Chimera
resistance
the Ratchet and Clank yeah they have
more successful ratchet and clanks but
they left resistance yeah yeah I would
love to see that come back no doubt for
me
um number one probably at least Sega or
some like you got to make a a Shinobi
game it's it's been a minute you know
what I'm saying this time it's time so I
like to see that um
from the mall since we had Jake from the
Marvel side either like a Marvel
Ultimate Alliance game again multi-plat
not just Nintendo
um or Marvel heroes that was my joint
and um make that make that come back
because that died prematurely that was
it was an MMO like Diablo style Marvel
game was amazing died for stupid reasons
and oh yeah oh man that was me and kite
boxers
oh my God and then um for me personally
for Xbox if the ABK didn't go through
and now you doing you got all them
studios please contact my man from High
Moon Studios that uh what's his name
David Teague I want my War Cybertron the
real Transformers games that he had that
he had homage and he knew he was the
comic book geek for Transformers those
games are revered not those whack movie
tie-in ones these ones and have him make
a true Cybertron game that's my joint
that's one of the hopes I hope for um
Activision Blizzard King the studios can
go back to doing other stuff as opposed
to Call of Duty stuff so that is mine we
finally gonna get into these topics
today
um addict you are up PlayStation
showcase sir
yeah so after two years of silence and
me and King uh always clowning it looks
like we're finally gonna get a
PlayStation showcase keep in mind we
will be live streaming it yeah this is
there Thursday it's Wednesday it's a day
this week Wednesday oh okay they're an
automatic show this week then so
um so we will be live streaming that you
know maybe we'll go uh maybe that will
be the attic show the live stream thing
I don't know yet uh but
we're gonna be doing that man and you
know I wanna I wanna start with Saul
because when it comes to PlayStation
show
what do you expect from this song do you
expect that like part of me wants to
think that they about to hit us with a
Spirit Bomb and I know none of you know
what that is but the party
this is like clouding me because I I
don't watch it
they're gonna hit us hard with with a
lot of games
they're gonna give a lot of stuff
information but then the other part of
me is like
are they like because to me with Xbox
like doing the things Xbox is doing and
where they've been so lackluster and
like especially after redfall like do
they have to go that one like I don't
know part of me thinks two years the
show I'm my expectations with this show
just because it's been so long since we
had a showcase not a state of play yeah
a showcase
makes me have a lot of expectations for
this particular showcase but what do you
think so I agree I agree they've been
quiet almost two years that's insane
that's insane and you know at a time
when you know when they both came out
when both consoles launched the Xbox
launched strong they launched they
launched strong
um the Xbox didn't really have a whole
bunch of first party stuff to go along
with with their launch and they had
Demon Souls they had a couple of things
um but it was it's one of those things
where they were if it felt like there
was if there was competition to be had
it felt like it was it was
at least
and looking at it and perceiving it it
felt that way so now you know Xbox has
had a couple of months of not the
greatest news or whatever games coming
out not the greatest
and I kind of see it as one of those
moments it this feels like one of those
moments that back in the in the Xbox One
PS4 generation it's a goal for the
jugular moment it it does feel like
we've been quiet two years we're going
let loose with everything we have in the
pipeline even if it's five years out I
don't know that's just the way it feels
right it you know they have no reason to
hold back King said this year which is
right they only really have Spider-Man
announced right and FF uh 16 which is
theirs is no one else is there so it's
an exclusive
um but yeah I I really do think they're
gonna Spirit Bomb us with with a whole
bunch of stuff and the thing about them
is that they've been real good about the
vast majority of that stuff actually
coming out and being quality so they
could say something they have that
cachet where they can say something five
years
except before Focus
except for that except for that I
misspoken my bad you know before spoken
forespoke yeah I don't know I haven't
played it I can't see it but do you
think we'll see Wolverine we will see
Wolverine oh you think so I think we'll
see we'll see a gameplay snippet at the
end of a trailer but again they I don't
think they want to take too much from
Spider-Man right Spider-Man but
Spider-Man but Spider-Man is really
close right Spiderman we're gonna be
getting gameplay soon of Spider-Man if
not here right we're gonna get tidbits
of that
um and we might get a gameplay Blowout
at some point you know fairly soon so I
wouldn't be surprised if we get a little
bit of Wolverine just an actual teaser
give us a tone for it kind of you know
what as opposed to just a little tone
piece they gave us you know him at the
bar and that was it I could see that
um all the metal gear rumor stuff that
they gave us the Wolverine how long was
that at that last showcase was it that
was two years ago two years ago that was
two years ago yeah very very long okay
so these dudes hold on hard they haven't
they haven't talked about anything which
is weird right they usually have
something and you know they have they
they kind of really stuck to their guns
when they said we're not really doing an
A3 thing when we're ready to talk we'll
talk and but this does feel like it is
planned it's like okay everybody has
that summer thing we're going to beat
them to the punch right and then and
then they're going to have to react to
us
um so I to me it feels like they're
confident it feels like they're
confident because again I don't really
see a reason why they would not talk
about things that are way out because
they've done it in the past yeah and it
hasn't really come back to bite them
right um you know we're hearing a whole
bunch of stuff Snake Eater uh remake
um you know again seeing Wolverine you
know the the things that they might have
in store with Konami right besides you
know maybe Castlevania or something like
that
um yeah so the thing about it is if if
they are deficient in first party stuff
being ready to show which I don't think
so I mean I see it goes to sushima next
year right so maybe they show it now
grub grub recently shot that down
because everybody thought uh Toshiba 2
would be here and then grub recently
shot that he's like he's got word that
it's not not gonna be there okay so yeah
I mean these guys that are in the know
are gonna have ideas of what you know
but again the whole place
yeah I know I know the bloodborne stuff
feels like it's time right if not if
you're not remaking a game that's still
that you know that that doesn't have
that much age on it whatever but I can
see at the minimum a 60 FPS patch at the
minimum
yeah maximum it's getting a remake right
um or uh you talk about a bloodborne too
obviously you know these guys are
working on Armored Core or whatever now
they just you know they finished Elden
ring
um but hey uh it's sitting right there
it's sitting right there and I don't see
how you would go I heard rumors about
blue point you don't give Blue Point the
bloodborne
you give them a remake sure I don't know
if you give him the sequel so
yeah I haven't I don't I try not to have
expectations for anything anymore right
I just go in and just with a black heart
yeah it just isn't always they always
under deliver right
mm-hmm and in addition to all that other
regular game stuff they need they need
to show stuff for psvr too oh yeah
definitely you don't need to show
anything for no PS VR too they just gave
you 40 games nobody's buying this thing
let's let the game said according to the
place
according to the PlayStation Vlog you're
invited and it says a wealth of new
games and a new IP are headed to PS5 and
psvr2 they are going to be talking about
psvr 2k oh man don't mess up my showcase
do you think that's possible that
because I mean I'm hearing people say
stuff like oh we're gonna get a
bloodborne thing I mean how many years
have we been here in that like do you
think because they've been gone so long
we expect so much content from them that
that it's kind of unrealistic for them
to meet that demand at this point I mean
it's we're always unrealistic with the
with our with our desires this is from
these companies right but Sony again
Sony's not afraid to talk about
something that's years out facts and
then so it you know they they'll get
they they don't care about they want to
get the wild moment in the moment right
now they'll worry about the pushback
later if something gets delayed or
something isn't as good as they'll worry
about that later but to get that now at
a moment where you can kind of see it or
Xbox you don't know how strong they are
right because again they're gonna they
can come back later and then you don't
know what Xbox is going to be willing to
show right
at the show Final Fantasy uh rebirth oh
I absolutely thank you
oh you don't think it's there no I think
I think we get another trailer I think
we had a trailer I will be very
disappointed if I see nothing but stuff
from other people like at this point
it's like yeah I just don't I get that
that's coming up for their platform and
if that has like a this year release
date that's fine but they've already
announced it's already announced this is
an exclusive I prefer stay to play deep
diving that with the release day like I
don't want so you don't want to see it
on the stage but we've already seen it
what did they show rebirth last I'm
trying to think a few years ago I think
no rebirth was shown at the end of last
year that's when they announced they
showed it when they were showing more of
the uh Crisis Core right yeah to me I
just prefer at this point is since that
game's now if they if they if that was
the the launch the
showing the game that's different like
formerly now it's already been announced
unless you got gameplay already I don't
want to see it but to me we still got a
decent they said it's coming out this
year I don't think it's going to come
out this year I think it's probably a
next year game if it is this year
then drop it but don't don't don't end
with it don't end with it okay okay
interesting I feel like they've been
gone for two years I'm not trying to
have them in with something that's
already been announced
I can I can see that my name what goes
to Sushi in the two I can see that
um but I I they look it's been fixing my
mind we're three years into the gym they
both got to talk they both gotta talk
they both really have to show like sure
I don't really care we're not doing that
12 month thing anymore obviously right
for Xbox I want to be wild yeah I want
and I don't necessarily some people feel
like it you got to be wild with just all
the stuff that you like or or the
Nostalgia fact or whatever no just show
me quality stuff
just show me everything you got on the
table that's it I don't really like
because you need people to get excited
right this is what I I hate this idea
that this this period of the Year even
though it's not quote unquote E3 anymore
it's about getting people excited about
the platforms
so you can get the 4.0 on them
like make sure the The Twig get the twig
and the giggle berries
so that to me they're both like again I
think this is going to be a kind of
crazy what they're gonna show
and if I have expectations I hope and
expect Xbox to do the same all right
fair enough Lord King PlayStation
showcase what's your thoughts
predictions were yet
I love this fan base man this man base
is is y'all are some beautiful toxic
individuals
the Moses the most beautiful toxic
individuals it'll be like King you can
hold the line all you want next week we
break it through
next week you know we're gonna have God
Hand and everything everything's gonna
beat him yo I love you guys because
y'all walk away from every state of play
every showcase oh yeah next one though
your next one so they double satisfied
yeah next one yo goes to shishima gonna
be there once he said that the
PlayStation VR gonna show up be prepared
to be disappointed
that's never been presents just go back
up the show urination Nation Oh man yo
yo somebody gonna rain on your parade
somebody's doing something they telling
you it's raining
all right guys my expectation this is my
expectation as a gamer let's go because
you guys is weirdos
that's your expectation my expectation
um I want all economy stuff that they
was talking about this is an old
showcase
when it was out there snitching
or this is what they were supposed to
talk about back when it was out there
snitching and writing they had to make
themselves look weak
now they already know the deal going
through
another this is the reason why they're
going early they had this this is
January during the February joint That
was supposed to show up
so they're like oh man that deal going
through once the EU fell they was like
ah yo next week we uh did you notice
once the news came out it was like next
week so this is the fetus showcase I had
it on Deck no it's not defeated this is
the fact that this is gonna be a very
strong Showcase from from all of the
individuals that I I mess with
um yeah it goes to shooting you ain't
gonna be there uh
this this is going to be a strong
showcase yeah and remember Sony doesn't
care to show you things that's going to
be here that's not coming out for years
but right they just want to keep you
stuck on your controller man sit down
play with this remake
um put a little bit of the square stuff
that we got going on over here we got
Spider-Man instead Hold This Hold Us
Down and then we see you uh two years
from now we got Wolverines at some time
and somewhere ever in the future and
that's what's gonna be I want all that
Konami stuff that he was talking about
okay Metal Gear I'm at the Silent Hill
and I'm at the Castlevania I want all
three of them uh I want to walk away
from I want all three of them exclusive
I don't care about uh the Kratos DLC
that these dudes is bantering in in the
background I don't care about that
um
maybe a new Ratchet and Clank side
mission joint that'd be nice that'd be
fun uh
maybe a new Sackboy Adventures for your
your PlayStation VR if if VR is going to
be there please put some of your main
IPS in VR showing me confidence in the
VR product so I know for a fact that you
guys plan to keep this thing around take
something that you're willing to invest
in and invest in it right don't give me
no sidebar uh Horizon call it a wild and
and tell me oh you know uh she's here
aloe is here but she's not here you know
you controlling uh dinkus
[Laughter]
you and dinkus you will make binkers go
up the
mountains will have to all other stuff I
I don't care for dinkus
right so you want the main character IP
if you're strong in something and you're
standing behind your product I don't
yell I'll hold the line and don't you
don't say yo don't put Halo head no put
Halo here put something in it man
show me your confidence so again I want
all those Konami stuff that y'all been
bragging about that y'all been talking
about and it's just me calling out you
PlayStation frauds because you do don't
really know what's going to be there
y'all just be spitballing throwing stuff
in the air oh we blood ball ain't gonna
show up it's gonna be uh 4K 60 frames
um we we also gonna have the new God of
War oh Wolverine gonna show up we're
gonna have full game trailer and
gameplay uh and it's gonna have VR
support so they doing too much
expectations that's what you're saying
and they all walk away with the Saints I
clown y'all every time you talking about
clown yeah you're gonna come out with a
canola tool or something like that
what did you do y'all had the Little
Indie little dudes that y'all's running
around yeah I thought that was gonna be
it for y'all it's gonna be a lot of
Indie stuff oh no some passion projects
and [__] say yeah we got an extra uh
paid for a mission
what's their biggest announcement for
them for Sony
something for VR come on see you wildly
man not for me I was hoping Silent Hill
I told you I want those Konami IPS that
we already know that they paid for that
they paid for that that's not in-house
I don't care like I don't
know since when they own and right this
is
and block stuff off
yo get your money hack games there's
gonna be plenty of that there's gonna be
some exclusive yeah sprinkle your cash
around cause your time is running out so
sprinkle it around as soon as that ABK
deal go out we ain't gonna be talking
about this stuff no more so sprinkle
your cash
Silent Hill please give me Silent Hill 2
remake some y'all the masters of the
Remake Go remix
collection this year
these dudes are hype or remakes
not one of these dudes say it's gonna be
a new Castlevania game no we're gonna
remake the first
um it's not gonna be a new metal gear
game no we're gonna remake Metal Gear
Solid
this part it's three yeah okay he was
only gonna remake Snake Eater and they
and they say oh we want we want to
remake bloodborne
now the sad part is he's not wrong no he
ain't wrong he's not wrong we talk about
new games over here y'all keep remaking
keep playing the same experience and
talk about it's new to me though shut up
man you Platinum that get out of here
you Platinum boys go show them true
instead of giving you tears to the
kingdom and they would have said we're
gonna give you breath of the wild again
in in a higher resolution uh a little
bit cleaned up you happy for that I
would have got it but I'm not like going
crazy
I I prefer anything over some of the
games I've played the past year yeah
I'll take tears to the kingdom over a
remake of something I did already give
me something different this is what I'm
trying to say I don't care if you
re-skinned it those are nice games that
you put on the side but let's get these
new experiences out let's the house of
Sony the house of ideas
obviously the people that had ideas are
gone
yeah I mean the only idea you got is
let's remake the Triple A bit I agree
with that right like and we is it and
this comes from the PS1 era love and I I
completely agree with that like there's
Tony back and PS2 as well PS3 is this
this PS4 weirdo dudes
got this strange energy around their
chest
strange energy Spirit bombs How You
Gonna remix the spirit boy we're gonna
send you the remix
best
songs we can make a new spare parts
my thing is I get mad at Xbox for not
even they know why don't we talk about
Xboxes
they know but this but the reactions to
so what Sony does right and it's just
like they know the reaction they'll get
to certain things yeah
I mean it's clear that the the the the
the customer has spoken yeah
sometimes I feel like they just it being
different for the sake could be a
different and just well Xbox has shown
that they want to differentiate
themselves
they've said Phyllis based obvious we
don't want to be a better version of The
Blue Team and a better version than the
red team he's literally said that right
but at the same time it's like making
everything there is there is something
to be said for yo King they remaking
their best hits from PS4
but see he's a Trophy Hunters uh these
are the we already established that
these dudes don't have jobs and he's
sick
when you established that their home
base don't have jobs we have to
established that the fan base don't
happen
and he played these games
where where is these where's these stats
that you're speaking I don't know go ask
one of those dudes who carries
established anyway go with the Remake
Posse
[Laughter]
better they better not come in another
remake next week if they remake The Last
of Us Again with Pedro that's our face
and for that new HBO Max feel Yo Face
y'all can go get that right now for
79.50
anyway I think it's my turn
yeah Bessie is oh my God they're
ridiculous
um yeah look oh I want to shout out dual
shocking says podcast module with a team
I was on there um yesterday
and they were talking they were doing
that prediction show too and um to me I
think one would think Last of Us
factions has to be a lock at this point
like we would need to see what's going
on with that game the multiplayer joint
see what's up Spider-Man 2 the question
I have will they have the release date
or will they wait until maybe like
another like state of play as it gets
closer supposed to be in September yeah
but did they announce did they
officially I don't think they officially
announced no I I heard rumors is like
the seventh or something like that yeah
when it start when is Starfield the
Starfield is oh what is it
I think they come out like probably a
week before star would feel but we know
it's the same month we just gotta figure
out the day but I'm curious to see if
obviously the showboat but if they um
give the release date then
um I think I agree with King though
psvr is going to be there psvr2 is going
to be there that it underperformed this
is like let's say the last chance but
this is they've got to make a strong
impression for those they make a a big
strong impression or just splashes it's
okay no no I'm sorry we will see new
games for sure I don't know how big the
impression's gonna be uh I mean they've
got this like a quarter of the show is
VR
well I mean I don't know how I don't
let's just go foreign
they got to get people confident in that
product because we saw the forecast they
did not reach those forecasts it
underperformed and this is like you know
a last shot to get people so I'm gonna
solve like if you could get like a a
half Half-Life Alex like if you had to
bet your life
would you would you
on guarding them like if they say you
listen man
you got bet your life if I have life
Alex gonna be there would you say yes or
no I'm laughing about life I bet my life
that PS VR games are going to be there
no no psvr games is gonna be there I'm
talking about that triple A Half-Life
alley they need it they need it do you
think it would be there
I'm not betting my life but I'm like
it's a good chance they try look they
got beat saved which is a big game in VR
like that regardless people's like that
is a huge deal is fantastic right so the
next thing is you need that
transformative experience to say okay
this is what you can do that you really
can't do anywhere else and we have it on
our platform and then like you said show
the new IPS that kind of have their
tried and true you know peanut butter
and jelly names you know like we said
you didn't have the alloy this time I
mean we had things but
but you need to have something with I
don't know Jim Sakai in it or something
you know you need something with
something with your big names you know
what I'm saying Uncharted you know
somebody got to be in VR to make people
go okay let me go rock out this is a
different you know bespoke experience
with this classic IP Legacy on it you
think this passion project is going to
take that deep of a uh a risk I mean
they don't what choice do they have at
this point the product is not
they literally themselves on the blog
post said look out for psvr2 titles on
the joint so I expected to be there so
that's that
um
[Laughter]
um I do think we're gonna get Hardware I
think we're gonna get Hardware this show
I think we're gonna get you know I agree
with Tom Henderson I think we're going
to get we're not I don't think we're
gonna get the pro but I think we'll get
the slim maybe we get the slim do you
think we get that uh the head out yes
that one I'm pretty confident that one
yeah yeah so you get the cue like the
the remote joint you know the remote
play the show is a little companion
thing now to King's credit
where they could get in trouble if they
spend too much time on hardware and they
spend too much time on VR that could
lose the audience a little bit and and
to be honest with you the way you're
talking like it might seem like that
might happen you got the VR you got this
this slim this handheld like they might
it's only an hour right so it to me
the pacing is gonna be kicked but all of
that's not gonna matter if they show
that AAA Banger that we didn't know
about or some big IP that is exclusive
and you go oh my God because you know
what's gonna happen so it's gonna be
some we gonna go oh what's that and then
we wait for the end and you're gonna see
it and say only old place
yeah and you don't see nothing else now
the king gonna pop bottles if it don't
say nothing at the end and then they go
to Twitter and people go yeah yeah guys
it's on it's on Xbox too that's what kid
gonna do to try to you're gonna try to
minimize anything they doing but that's
gonna be the key what big third party
exclusive whether it be silent hill two
Metal Gear Solid three that if they
could snap something that takes the soul
that's gonna hurt if people gonna go oh
oh God we could we could only do it over
there
that's and that's what they tend to do
that show gonna be a six out of ten yeah
I know you coming in I know which
position you're coming right
so yeah that's what I got face
to walk this back I'm not walking
anything back I'm going into this
line for at that point
about me
when I'm right
I will say this if you write about this
show being garbage when I'm right
you guys can't stop me and I'm telling
you now this show gonna be a six out of
ten for that PS3 so you telling me for
two years they wait for two years it's
gonna be a garbage show they ain't gonna
be nothing fired
hold up you know what we're gonna do you
know what we're gonna do we're gonna
make this interesting
I'm gonna get Jada to do the reaction I
want him here so bad yo I I want him to
hear so bad like you realize
I want as much PlayStation dudes here so
bad I want you dudes here so I want
y'all to be enforced I want y'all to be
having your hands in the air pumping
your chest and as I start there laughing
at your showcase and deflating you and
telling you this is exact I told you
what was gonna happen to you but you did
listen yeah
we'll see what happens Nick says when
King sees the Konami announcements this
week the new say will behold the line
for me
[Laughter]
anyway that's what I got look at the
super chances
he is right though if if this Show's bad
oh we've never been hit from here and we
got to remember too I just don't I don't
see how it can be bad like I'm gonna be
realistic we gotta remember too how many
of these uh these service games are we
gonna see at this one oh that fought to
the kicks that that fits in the kicks
there it is
let him cook
the momentum cook
we got um Nintendo
uh yeah five dollars for chat remember
the 2016 E3 of Dreams was the third year
of the of the Gen this is the time where
Sony and Xbox need to put everything out
yes at least talk about it let's go we
got Robert kellett Calvin Call of the
Wild two be fired
then we have Jenna Hayes oh that's a
that's a name
brother you resemble George Clinton from
The Funkadelics
I don't know I I don't know I don't know
George couldn't play in video games one
nation under fill Xbox don't fail me now
stop listening
classic then we got Robert Kelly but
remakes are the best games this year for
tears of the Kingdom I want new and
hopefully Xbox picks up that gold medal
this year going giving gong Jimmy the
Bros giving Jimmy the brunch
over 800 in the chat man hit that like
button man hit that like and share it
out I know you PlayStation dudes is here
hit the like button we got Robert Kelly
Vision confident either Freeman was an
NVR they got Alex fans
it's not like a sideshow character it's
so messy then we got Nintendo Taco two
thousand chat PS Vita abandoned psvr
abandoned the psvr two okay I thought
you thought about the abandoned game
he's talking about literally being
abandoned yeah and this is their last
shot yeah peripherals they haven't been
that strong suit we're gonna have to say
that no never been yeah
Barton goes 17 two pounds Super Chat
y'all seen that Gran Turismo trailer
trash I liked it actually I bought a
movie
for a race again to make it interesting
excited I thought it was actually pretty
good that's pretty much the only way you
could I want to know how they expect a
racing game to go
it's based on a true story the guy like
really played Gran Turismo and went and
compete for real like
nah that looks about as good as they
could make it yeah High gamer score in
it
this guy right here
hold on somebody holding the line
Anonymous just cop that hold the line
okay
[Laughter]
that's it we're caught up all right no
doubt all right I think this is King I'm
gonna set them up European commission
approves Microsoft activist what
happened
oh yeah it's always on now you're paying
commissioner approves Microsoft
Activision Blizzard deal that's to allow
players to stream the Activision plus
the games on competing services for free
so yeah it was a a big vote and having
to approve the deal so it um just leaves
the CMA and FTC as the uh the final
Roblox so it looks like the remedies
that Microsoft proposed for cloud gaming
were sufficient to fully address The
Regulators concerns so of these remedies
was a free license to consumers in the
eea that would allow them to stream via
any cloud game streaming services of
their choice all current and future
Activision Blizzard PC and console games
which they have a license and then the
second point of contention that that
really helped Microsoft with the
remedies was um a corresponding free
license to cloud game streaming service
providers to allow EAA based game Gamers
to stream any Activision Blizzard PC and
console games and um the EU had a final
thing to say about it these licenses
will ensure that Gamers that have
purchased one or more Activision games
on a PC or console store or that have
subscribed to a multi-game subscription
service that includes Activision games
have the right to stream those games
with any cloud game streaming service of
their choice and play them on any device
using any operating system remedy also
ensures that Activision games available
for streaming will have the same quality
and content as Games available for
tradition download so this is a huge
huge win for Microsoft a lot of people
felt that if this they didn't beat with
the EO this was probably a wrap a lot of
people you know didn't think this would
give Microsoft any life if you know but
here we are and King
I told you guys
the EU has signed the treaty
and the EU has fell in line two that's
out there that's the CMA and FTC we'll
have the FTC in litigation for years
all you guys that held the life you're
doing fine they said we were dead we are
not dead for the people for the people
at home how can they help homes
well they can just go buy a cop a shirt
as I said
you mustered heart dude we were finished
you thought you were coming and checking
out a corpse
popped up and surprised you they thought
it was over they thought it was over oh
you we have a Pathway to Victory and
victory will come through this is
exactly what I told you so General I
just want to get the Strategic battle
plan here strategy you know because you
be in the general so was the EU the key
for your success to get this done they
didn't expect the EU to fall in line
they thought the EU and the CMA was
definitely going to be in cahoots
together the only people in cahoots is a
CMA in the FCC so is this a pincer
attack so now that we got the EU to get
on at all those countries then you just
one General you won China has signed the
pack as well
this is what I'm talking about China
sorry China's son and China said we want
no beef with you so then you got nearly
38 countries all on board with you Joe
that want this dude to get done does
this put the uks in a toughness do you
got the UK boxed in general
UK
is going to get what they're going to
get like Satya said let's let it all
play out oh yo yo what's up you had that
face so sweet are you are you saying
General that you go if they don't get in
line if they don't hold the line that
you gonna cut the UK on this business
those dudes would be eating biscuits and
Pelican babies
guess who's gonna lay down you
38 States will be eating five and you'll
be sitting there eating Popeye's
Biscuits by yourself so don't Call of
Duty no Call of Duty no Activision
Blizzard so how do you deal with the FTC
cause that'll be a lot of pressures on
oh we just throw them in court oh so you
just wait so you're gonna move the game
you gonna move for
we have the best lawyers we are spending
68 billion a lot of you mustard seeds
can't wrap your head around that number
so we're gonna spend 68 billion on
Studios what do you think we're gonna
spend to get this over the line we want
this we gonna have it we want you and we
gonna have it we can do this
stuff
but at the end of the day you're gonna
be mine
and there you have it the general has
spoken he's held the line I gotta give
it to him man no one has believed in
Xbox more than this man this deal I mean
definitely was going back and forth and
um it looks like you know at the end of
the day this is breathing life into the
hopes of the deal well I think uh Fox
patents and a couple other opponents
agree with King they feel it's only
about even Michael packter I believe was
kind of saw this he wanted a few that
like King that really saw it playing out
this way so huge victory for the general
oh yeah of course man what I want to say
is first of all I want to thank
everybody that support the the hold the
line on the show for sure um you know we
out hit 10 toes down in the street and
we had a slings and the arrows and the
distractors are trying to do things
they're trying to do all types of things
trying to tell you why not to hold the
line
we will hold the line
and we are good nothing you saying right
now is going to distract us we're moving
forward when y'all said the deal was
done and dude was running for the hell
these Mustang hard Kool-Aid drinking
dudes actually told you that it ain't
gonna happen right then you'll woke up
to my news
yeah shout out to Aaron Greenberg and um
supporting putting out the Tweet retweet
and showing support
um
when this deal goes through oh that's
your greatest this your greatest thing
ever like I told people I said if if
this deal go through and get signed we
this is literally the coronation of King
David this is everybody at the at the
lowest point abandoning Xbox telling
they came on here waiting for you to
capitulate and say fire field get off
Xbox and you your belief in this
platform there's no other believes in
Xbox one but this would be your greatest
Victory and then have a good showcase on
top of that then you you ride it to the
sunset as a legend and when the Xbox
showcase come up it ain't gonna be no
remixes
it ain't gonna be no hey let's try this
again a little bit faster it ain't gonna
be none of that baby
you're gonna have a new experience you
already know what Starfield bringing to
you new experiences Galaxy's Far Far
Away fun fun son y'all talk about the
same old stuff and the new type of skin
man Hey listen everybody
set your PC stuff down
anyway so we heard from the general look
the he's looking good right now sounds
but we had to admit it he's looking good
right now as far as the deal going
potentially just going through through
Brute Force off of this button I get my
balls off that addict who cares every
week that we talk about this time he
loves
to talk about litigation and the deal so
what says addict that EU passed the deal
to approve Activision Blizzard cake
as long as this passed or not passed and
I don't have to talk about it no more
that's that that is what I want that's
what you want you just responsibility
I ain't trying to talk about this
forever
forever and ever like I really feel like
I'm in like forever land at this point
you've got me man
all right what about this question if
the deal goes through
is King coronated at that point do we
coordinate him for believing in Xbox
when no one else did
I mean at that point like there's plenty
of people but King definitely been on
his in his back so actually it's like
what we cannot not give him props no for
sure I mean oh sorry to be fair none of
y'all believed it was gonna happen so
none of y'all should be owning this I
was I did say I did say a big assistant
or dude I said the deal was going
through I always you know to be fair
from the very beginning none of y'all
even did it wasn't a thought in your
mind what I mean y'all honesty should be
honest
I'm trying to urinating yourself that's
what I'm trying to do see I gave you
yourself to Dollar stuff when you write
and don't let no Persona happen at the
Xbox show because I'm coming for you sir
code for you sir again
we can get that remake but if there's no
six there
I win sir it's a bit of it you're a
bitter individual anyway moving on solve
your thumb please
what is it
um yeah I always figured the EU stuff
was going through because the EU and the
CMA just did not see I had anything see
those are the two that fight just to
just you know they fight each other so
it's one of those things I I did not see
it but the good thing about the eu's
arguments is that they were sound oh
logical logical sound arguments no and
and they and they fully admitted if
Microsoft had not capitulated the
certain things they would not have
approved it yeah and they were very keen
they were very keen to say that like
it's like yo if you don't if these
things are not are not taken care of
we're not approving this and Microsoft
went ahead and did it
um so in in looking at that it's like
all right now we have the FTC the FTC
Lena Khan getting grilled about it okay
you just you you no conversations with
Microsoft now I don't want to talk to
y'all no and it now more than ever it
looks it's so obvious it was obvious to
us right that this was a political thing
it's about showing strength FTC and just
showing strength against you know
against big Tech and that's it but at
the end of the day the arguments don't
hold water so what my thinking is that
before we even reach the point where
we're going to court with this I think
this they're going to reach some sort of
agreement do you agree with pacta
I really do I mean again it makes them
it makes them look quote unquote good
right and and that they're sitting down
at the table and talking right
Microsoft is willing to capitulate the
damn net anything right I'm gonna talk
about that in a minute with the with the
Nvidia stuff
um like they don't care at the end of
the day
like I said before this the strength
that they're showing in the cloud space
is the only thing really to be worried
about but at this point it's too late
because the thing is
they're just they're giving their games
to everybody now right they're gonna get
money from all this they're going to get
considerably richer from growing all of
this but at the end of the day everyone
every plaque they're not saying no it
has to be on Azure no it has to be
through game pass it could be piecemeal
it could be all a card it could be Game
Pass if you want to sit down and have
that discussion as well
um they're not forcing it on anyone so
what can you say if they're the only
ones in a position to do that and when
you look at when you look at what you're
looking at in terms of overall growth
and how the space is going to grow if
you want that to grow on any level then
you need to allow this to happen right
and regardless of what you think about
you know these these Pie in the Sky
questions about what Microsoft is going
to do with that
if you have that argument cool I can see
where hey hold on this is this Microsoft
thing
you know spread across the cloud is is
something much bigger than just the
gaming aspect of it but since the
argument is the gaming aspect of it well
no that's just a smaller piece of the
pie it isn't necessarily that important
right
um what it does gives them it gives them
inroads into all these other places so
again I the EU I figured the EU stuff
was going to go through because again it
just they they
they're never going to agree with CMA
just on principle and what I'm glad
about is that the arguments were sound
arguments right and and that's it and I
FTC stuff I was supposed to be August
yeah I I I foresee something happening
before that because you just don't want
to you're wasting taxpayers money like
just get it done and at least sit at the
table if you sit at the table and come
away from the table like nah okay fine
even if it's a dumb argument but you
didn't even sit at the table yeah that
was different and you put yourself in a
position to be questioned for that wait
what does this mean right and it's
stupid because everybody knows it's
politics but then you have to go through
the to the to the steps right you have
to go to the proper steps and show why
you don't want this to go through and
they have to prove all of this and waste
taxpayer money to prove all of this and
then I don't know if you saw us all the
CMA right now is getting grilled because
they're saying that they did the math
wrong as far as the the Xbox users and
and saying that everyone on game is a
cloud user which is not the case right
that is not the case right so they right
they formulated arguments to fit their
argument
um and it's not the case they they
skewed how they looked at it in order to
come to a certain conclusion right and
you can't do that right you weren't
being objective so
I the the crazy thing is is I don't know
what happens with the CMA yeah
but but if this goes through and they
have to capitulate and and this decision
gets overturned historically overturned
yeah that would be right that's
Parliament yeah shout out to Parliament
pick up my Parliament shout out to the
Lord the problem House of Lords of the
house you can question Parliament
couldn't question but can they overturn
I don't know we got to see that that
part is the gray area I want a really
quickly shout out shout out to Legend
Paris Lockhart he said I'll see y'all at
fairfest 2023 I was the last buyer he
says hold the line that's Samos 23 La
hashtag Xbox hashtag Xbox is definitely
embracing hold the Lion King there's no
doubts
I can't wait
[Laughter]
I can't wait for y'all to hear me yo
Chuck is right now we just hold it
some of your concluding Buzz I know I'm
done man I'm done this is very again
this is interesting because now
it's all up to the FTC if the FTC goes
through and if it goes through in a way
that makes them
look Petty and haven't been stupid for
even taking them to court
um yeah I don't I it's going to be
interesting to see what the statement
from the CMA is at that point in time
because again at that point everybody
else is is accepting of it is there a
situation where you just okay we're
moving forward without you
uh good luck getting Call of Duty right
you know and going back to satya's uh
point about it we'll see now they're not
gonna pull all of Microsoft's business
out of the YouTube
Sports the scenario that's not happening
but I mean the at that point the
pressure will be on and they don't have
an argument they don't have a leg to
stand on with the arguments they've made
so unless they reframe the argument
and I don't see the UK lawyer the one
that um has been uh doing this that the
Hogue does yeah
um he was on
he was on guys's podcast yesterday and
he said like the odds of this being
passed like 20 30 20 32. yeah he says
you can't just tell a government like
that that you're not going to abide to
their raw their laws like it it doesn't
work that way
so meaning the whole thing if they
continue to hold out the whole thing is
done
that's that's pretty much how he worded
it now obviously you know we might have
to get him on the show to be a little
bit more specific on what he got but the
way it seemed like he's like look like
you know people think that that's easy
that's not something that he doesn't
think Microsoft is willing to do in the
yeah and if that is the case right but
if that the case this is what I think is
going to happen this is it's against the
law it's not just like a matter of you
know we're going to do this it's against
the law there it's not there right yeah
yeah we're all over here
but I care about what you do in your
house stay over there yeah that that's
the thing it's against the law that my
thing is this right if that is the case
and for whatever reason like we don't
know the details of this it can't go
through if they if they're the holdouts
right whatever the case may be there's
going there all the remedies I talked
about the remedies there are ways for
this to go through you can piece
Activision off you could do it again
what you could do a whole bunch of stuff
said it wasn't false part it was Luke
Steele continue yeah sorry the lawyer
there's a lot of ways there's a lot of
ways that this can still go through just
not in in the form that it is now and
again that's that's just business that's
what you do to get things to happen if
you you know if you have too many
roadblocks right you go around it
somehow it's just one dude
look
unlike saw King I was with you on this
deal going down to why I saw things I
wasn't but um uh I seem to I what yeah
is the moment that I the first time I
mentioned it when I when I willed it
into existence well what into existence
when I willed the just the feeling to
existence
nah bro
I was like yeah that's not gonna happen
like because he got that initial thing
yeah
right you owned it you stood up on it
but you left that square
so you can't be upset when I stand on
the Square that you left oh no no no
wait wait I never walked away from this
thing it ain't gonna happen oh I just
don't I just I don't have a I don't have
a dog at a fight I'm if it happens fine
if it doesn't happen it's fine I don't
care no I have a dog
and the dog in the fight is holding a
lot it's holding a lot what do you
understand
look do I get so I was right with even
suggesting what's the next acquisition
for Xbox and we laughed about the room
and he was right on that now that we've
established that they they went for the
acquisition that it became is the deal
going through or not it's still not
going through and that's the only thing
I want to stand on that I've always said
if it came down to logic and reason this
deal should go through but it's not
harming competition with the number one
guy talking about it they're not going
to be able to survive snitching over
there
I've always said that and I've always
said out as a nascent market now granted
you know I understand that you might I
understand that they're powerful in
Cloud I've always said that and that
they're gonna have to show the things
that they're going to do you know from a
concession standpoint to make people
comfortable with them in that space
because that is azure backbone is a
powerful backbone they have I'm not
gonna minimize that but it just goes to
show you look all these was at 38
countries now
have said we have no problem with this
you know on both fronts and to me where
I think it's problematic for both the
CMA and the um you actually more
problematic for the FTC the ftc's
argument for reason for blocking it'll
see a very reasonable block of two
different reasons and the reason that
they're saying what FTC and CMA don't
even agree because to CMA says yo Call
of Duty ain't no issue whereas the FTC
is like yeah Call of Duty is too much
for them so I think I'm with you on on
the fact that whatever this timeline is
that they could officially push the deal
through they're going to try to force it
through now the key is going to be the
CMA that I agree with addict and what
was going on as far as like how no he
didn't change his name to holding the
live addict I'm done
the thing the thing is you know again I
don't know British law I don't know you
know profess to know how they go over
there but I just looked at the EU
situation is huge because like SOB said
I know the EU because I you know this
cuts off I threw logic out the video
with this at one point I said this is
about politics I said so if it's about
politics I got my politic hat on there's
no way the EU alongside with the UK
based on politics alone in history so
I'm gonna go with that and then if I'm
going politics FTC could say they're
going to capitulate and then they can
say oh but we fought the good fight see
guys we we stood up to about yourself we
made them change those rules because
they would be an evil with Call of Duty
and then they could capitulate and
somehow have a concession whatever I
don't know if the CMA because I agree
with that it does sound very long shoddy
based on British law I don't know all
that part but I will say there's a lot
of pressure on them with all these
countries is agreeing except you it
looks bad now the key becomes now this
Microsoft move forward and say okay
we're just gonna carve you out we're
gonna decouple you get Game Pass and you
get no cloud or you just don't get some
part of the package I agree solved
they're not gonna move the whole bikers
off business out of here okay that's too
extreme but they're gonna find a way
strategically you know what it reminds
me of
okay you're gonna remember this remember
when 360 first started hitting this
stride and this was Peter Moore before
he went to EA remember EA was funny
Style with EA Games and they wouldn't
let the maddens come over and it was
about we don't want our Network on Xbox
Live and all this and it took about a
year to before those games came over so
I think the deal gets done even if it's
not in the immediate future with UK
based on this appeal can't happen or is
it illegal or whatever I think over time
because you there's going to be one
group
changing their system centers to try to
be something else yeah so we'll see
we'll see I'll be that that that's how I
feel I think it is strong for Xbox right
now I think they're gonna fight tooth
and nail that EU just gave them the
Boost they needed the battery in their
back they are going to go all the way
with it and I agree with King they
definitely held the line and it's it's a
fight now it's it's not over it's going
through hella high water it's going to
go through in some way or some version
of it is going through that's how I see
it so that's where I'm at and uh we're
gonna move on and we're just going to
combine your topic down just uh yeah
just combine it because it's Cloud it's
cloudy yeah you know so uh solve you're
right man what's going on with GeForce
now what's what's happening yeah so you
guys remember that earlier in the year
when Microsoft was just handing out
10-year deals wholesale you got a 10
year dude you got it you're like right
uh one of those deals which is very
interesting to me
was with Nvidia right
and what's interesting about this deal
is and well okay so what happened is
finally the first PC games that are
coming out of that deal are finally
starting to hit nvidia's GeForce now uh
service cloud service
that cloud service is to me objectively
the best cloud service out there for
gaming right now
um
so it's just super interesting because
you you see where Microsoft is willing
to go in order for all of this to happen
to the point they don't care if your
servers are Azure servers
to see this happening
a shows that they're looking at the
bigger picture right and the bigger
picture is
getting what I always thought about what
game pass meant and what where Xbox was
going it's like we need to be everywhere
right I don't care how
I don't care how we get there it doesn't
matter and it's if there's one thing
about Xbox lately that they don't have
what I wish they had a little bit of was
Hubris but that's fine
because this is allowing them to see
this Grand picture about
the Xbox ecosystem being everywhere and
not caring I remember for a while we
were thinking about everything is going
to have to be Game Pass right right if
you you're gonna have to bend and need a
game pass and then you'll be able to get
this now there's this two-prong approach
now where it's like okay now on the
gaming Cloud side doesn't matter it
could be we can have it piecemeal and
like and the details of what we talked
about with the EU deal is that now you
can have you can get a license for the
game one time right one time and you're
playing anywhere you feel like playing
yeah and they're they're making it as
simple as possible which is a far cry
from what we saw at the beginning of the
Xbox one generation right where was this
convoluted it was all so to me it's just
it's super interesting because G-Force
now to me and all of its different
iterations is the best cloud gaming
service out there right now and for
Microsoft to be like okay cool you get a
10-year deal here's gears five starting
next week gonna start giving you more
we're gonna give you death loop we're
going to get you grounded and get you
pen to met
it's it's crazy because
more and more I see people talking about
GeForce and I was like hey man that top
tier whatever it is I don't know how
much it is it's like 15 a month dude
you're getting 40 90 quality yeah
um all the bells and whistles HDR all
that stuff and it's running super well
and the fact that they don't care that
it's outperforming Azure in that regard
doesn't matter
and that to me that's the big picture
stuff I see you know the Xbox stuff I
wanted to be successful as a brand right
but I really do think I know King always
talks about PlayStation is going to be
an app first right but it kind of feels
like Xbox One at first they want to be
the app you know what I'm saying but I
to me it's just this is this is big
because G4 is now kind of Trumps them
very well and and even again we don't
have we don't have stadia anymore that
Tech in a lot of ways was kind of
superior yeah
um so and I'm sure if stadia were around
they'd have a 10 years
that's so crazy if they understand that
they would literally benefit from this
deal right so the only ones that really
don't have a 10-year deal yet is Luna
right it's Amazon and that goes back to
to to a speculation that maybe them or
maybe Google might be getting into bed
with PlayStation if that is the case
right so um I just this is
this this kind of went by the wayside
but I'm like this is huge because again
this is objectively my my view the best
cloud gaming streaming thing going on
right now and they were just like here
you go take our games take our games
yeah um and and that is only going to
expand and they talked about how right
now it's piecemeal but we're going to
talk about how we can integrate game
pass into that it's going to be it won't
be it won't force you to do it but it's
going to be an option and once you get
that right that's where I really do
start to think like haha
then we talked about you know Game Pass
taking over the world and the
possibility of that and
they just got to keep getting more games
right for me you got to feed that Beast
right you got to keep people interested
but the fact that it's going to be
everywhere it really is it's a it's a
it's a scary thought about where they
can reach where all of these different
companies a varying quality too again
all of these other we don't know how how
great these other cloud services are
they gave 10 year deals to but but they
are the prolific ones in their sort of
respective areas right right uh
geographically
so they they have all the touch points
right so is this web sort of taking over
the world in a little bit and uh again
G-Force now is a big one it really
really is kind of important so yeah you
don't mind attic if I could jump in and
Skip because I do have some balls like
kick soft God Be Inspired can I tell you
I appreciate you care about none of them
I figured that's why I was like I
figured this beautiful let me skip a
little bit
it
I'll take your turn I take your turn
they can they can get they can put
clouds
streaming Tech and refrigerators
[Music]
bro I appreciate you no I mean it's big
because I speak to your brother a lot
sorry and Kai and that's where my
thoughts come from yeah excited about it
goes so hard for G-Force now and he's
just like called the tech it's just
insane I remember trying it once like a
year ago and I was super impressed like
super impressed and the fact that again
what's interesting is like you said this
Tech is in some instances Superior to
what Azure is doing because what we know
about Azure is you know when you're
doing it on Xbox at least you know you
go into a series X like with them you go
into like a 30 80 and then the highest
tier you go to a 40 90 with 4K HDR you
know and 120 hertz it's insane so the
cool thing about it it also reminds me
of like how this is what excites me
about the wrong Ally because it's like
we're at that point now where it's like
we don't care what storefront you buy it
on if you got the license then you got
the ability to stream it and that's what
GeForce now is doing so this is where
game is going that that that you you see
the and to your point this is huge
because technically this is their
competitor like this is who's supposed
to be fine so they're like nah you get
that
you could still write I think gears is
the first game that's coming over
definitely gears is out already yeah
kids that flute that's where it's going
and and in a sense it's kind of crazy
how quick they did it yeah super quick
it you know what's interesting at it the
timing started doing yeah like it was
like you rate depressed the button the
minute the EU went through you like it
boom so typical that signifies what kids
talk about they going hella high water
you we dare you stop this because
technically the deal ain't fast yeah and
again they're not doing but they're not
they're not doing activism
because they were so hard bent on
getting this deal to go yes it doesn't
go through and they have to deal with
all of these things and these contracts
that got into place trying to get the
deal to go through because I think a lot
of this only works if they actually
successfully do what's up to me a lot of
this only works if you have the Supreme
confidence that what you gonna do what's
going on
so to me it becomes down to even if the
to me it's about I don't CMA is the wild
card the FTC I get that says that
they're trying to steamroll them that
they are trying to debow them there's
nothing you can do to stop this it's
weird doing this and if you we dare you
challenge Us in court because nothing
like this to me is a slap in the face
yeah it's like what you gonna do we say
what we'll see you in court the deal is
out while it's in court so we gonna get
this and we're gonna keep it popping
that's how I see it you know what I mean
but sorry again no no I'm just laughing
I find all this funny dude it's like
yeah cause you see me black hey Kings
[Laughter]
[Music]
shout out to the team you know I seen uh
Sarah Bond she put the Tweet out shout
out to the Queen Sarah ball put the
Tweet out and then uh your man's was
outside kid your man was outside Phil
Dominus Maximus Aurelius Spencer today's
announcement marks a big milestone in
our promise to bring more games to more
people however they choose to play and
then uh this was a quote tweeting Sarah
Barb's tweet she said starting today on
Nvidia GeForce now members can stream
gears five with death blue grounded and
pentiment on May 25th just the first
step in our commitment to make our PC
games globally available through a
variety of cloud gaming Services yo
forget it yo listen listen what day is
that PlayStation uh showcase oh it is
the next day shout out to my man
this is the day you rock it we're
dropping on your date shout out to my
man
it's the next day it's the next day
shout out
hey it didn't go through push it though
yeah I told you to hold the line
y'all are in trouble when the CEOs say
you know what forget what we got going
on in court put it out on a date
yo big Bank take a little break okay yo
I knew it was something the date felt
kind of funny I was like
um
wait a second this date is up this is
the PlayStation showcase day
and the film was like uh you know what
drop it on the head B
I can't
your group
not the gas base
oh my goodness
the timing is interesting I will say
that the time this is what I asked for
that's why I told you he turned to Darth
Vader now he dropping his album All Day
album that's what we do it this is a
Sith move if this ain't a Sith move like
normally nice Phil would have been like
let them have their week Today Show
and then we'll drop he coming for your
head B y'all mess with the wrong dude
all that snitching and right now with
the whip it's outside it's outside y'all
sit there you want black stuff oh you
want block stuff let me show you how you
ain't blocking nothing
anyway
that's my boss baby and there you have
it kids the talking album release dates
That's all folks that's all so let's get
some chats get out of here because oh
God a second all right unless I'm gonna
do the poll yeah go ahead all right do
IL people with the European Commission
Now approving the Microsoft Activision
Blizzard deal how confident are you that
Xbox can still move forward with this
acquisition the choices are hey not
confident King FTC and CMA I still gonna
block this deal Hold the Line will be in
there somewhere maybe
be very confident Xbox beats the FTC in
court and carves out the UK he's gonna
put C for holding oh I see I don't care
we with kick David we held the line this
is gonna be the first time in a long
time that c wins
we shall see no doubt anyway uh we want
to get these super chats yes sir we got
a techno cave man remember for 35 months
Lord bronze Hold the Line another one
that's all that we got Jay Rembert two
dollar super chat hit that like button
thanks that's a little hit that like
and we have puckish Rogue one hundred
two dollars per chat General Fleece
Johnson is in the house
fleece he said oh cause he said he gonna
get it he wants you that's what that one
that we got it's Von zadori two pound
super chat you guys made me laugh love
this show
then we have full lobby with the seven
dollars of the chat on the topic of ABK
what's your thoughts on OverWatch 2's
PVE mode being scrapped at least the
story campaign is still coming in August
told them frauds they don't care about
that single player but anyway I got
killed for that but I'll move on yes
look at that that's wild
um people paid for that then we have
Robert Kelly Two Dollars Super Chat uh
well the FTC and CMA Hold the Line
then we got Gamers play HUD x0 with the
uh NBC 29 months remember for 29 monthly
bronze Hold the Line sometimes you need
pressure and heat to create a diamond
Xbox we play games here
apparently I don't but let's go
but let's go let's go here we have a
cipher pole 92 member for one year 10 10
pounds Super Chat speaking as a UK
resident do not be surprised if our
government approves the deal to save
face in order to stay a tech Hub
internationally they already lost arm
Holdings to the New York Stock Exchange
yeah we know about you know blocking the
arm deal salute to someone holding the
line they did yo they ain't eating this
whole Salon I'm loving it I'm loving it
I swear and yo when you get your merch
please
if I don't follow you already I'm
definitely gonna follow you I don't hold
my followers behind any pay wall like
some of these weirdo
like the favorite dude that you capping
for don't follow you don't play no games
with you and he's out there asking you
for giving up bucks I'm playing games
with y'all guys and I'm following
everybody back there follow me factual
dude
two weeks in a row get a job
Super Chat don't know if you guys
mentioned this already but I think
pulling the Activision deal from the UK
would do more harm than Sony's install
base than Microsoft
[Laughter]
[Music]
dropping his album on the same day of
the PlayStation showcase
there we go hard to knee with the five
dollars
Microsoft promised to not close until
May 22nd with the gamers lawsuit that's
up tomorrow this will be an interesting
week yes it will it will it'll be
interesting to see how Microsoft play
this with that whole situation but they
just closed this deal tomorrow I know
some it's gonna be interesting anyway
that's all I got Lord addicts what do
you say to find people before we roll up
out of here pretty sure we're coming
through uh definitely check out our um
reaction because I'm sure if this show
is is mid king king's gonna be extra on
that live stream King's gonna be extra
on Twitter you know he's gonna be extra
on the next podcast cake is always the
funniest when there's a whack indie game
on the Sony stage he's hilarious so
please yeah and I'm gonna reach out to
j-dub because we're gonna get someone in
there to go back I want more PlayStation
dudes today okay we'll get J dub and
Blaze
board stuff we can find people find you
what you got going on sir not playing
games damn it
I'd be a theme with this podcast oh my
goodness good luck okay
see if I can play some tears of the
Kingdom this week God forbid I can play
some tears of the Kingdom oh yeah I'm
gonna try to do that but yeah shout out
to Jake Solomon man oh yo great great
energy great great it's funny because I
was I was looking up stuff King Kings
Kings crazy rant made me forget all
about him being oh yeah you found info
on him because I was like there's no
Wiki page on him it's just what we know
of his gaming Guy Code
and he's a real cool dude I'm excited
for Twitter LinkedIn yeah regular dude
just good dude man love the energy no
doubt yeah and that's it uh one more
Super Chat real quick yeah baby five
dollars Super Chat got a cop a Hold the
Line sir all right purchase for any
channel but I'm a Believer oh that's
love that's love Saloon to the realm for
turning this into a movement like we
gonna hold that line
to the realm I love it it's beautiful
certain exec's out there talking about
my goodness
you could you could be mad the people
who they feel it's all like what but you
can't deny them you're gonna have to
send me me and call okay yeah I need my
whole line
I want to take talk for the gym I'm
gonna take time no no I'm talking about
for the uh for the LA trip yeah oh I
need dude well since this new merch you
may get it because old merch oh you'll
get it you'll get it next year yeah it's
new merch they send this or set on time
to do that today yeah we need to order
today so we don't have to wait six weeks
because
oh cool Lord King
man let me tell you um you guys are uh
it's a humbling experience but first let
me say uh salute to Jake Solomon yes
to find a kindred spirit like us comic
book dudes it's something to find a
comic book dude right gaming dude of
course but he had the trifecta he had
boxing because I was talking about
boxing and he watched the fight last
night right so and then he had comic
books and to like Dr Doom um that's
fantastic that's very rare and and
honestly you know to be in steeped in
video games as he is and and to give
real life stories about stuff uh humble
uh generous dude with his time because
he gave us a wealth of time and
knowledge and gym facts so if we didn't
get the chance to see that interview
early on please go back and watch the
beginning of the show so you can uh get
a chance to see this fine individual so
I salute you so thank you for showing up
on our platform and giving us a wealth
of knowledge uh in in the spare
um your games are phenomenal and um I'm
telling you this was uh cognito's uh I
will you know uh to say it to to get
this interview he's been championing in
this game more than everybody uh and
even the DLC everything every week he
goes and you know he has a new convert
for this game
um graphic God yo I love you
I love you because it reinforces uh my
belief in individuals I if if I rock
with you I rock with you you know um
people know that like I'm not phoning
I'm not fake if I rock with you I
somebody else has submitted something
and shout out to him I really respected
your piece in fact
um but I had commissioned graphic God
and graphic God is like my right hand
man me and him we have some body go
cause I can give them something that we
can run with it and hit me back and
we'll talk so graphic God is the um the
artist behind the hold the line and um
we talked about the the animation we
talked about the shirt we talked about
the beat that you're able to use yeah
he's he's a phenomenal person so I want
everybody to you know go follow if you
don't follow graphic God go follow him
now if you need a designer for anything
uh artistic wise hit him up his prices
are reasonable and he's very easy to
work with this guy takes great Direction
and he has great vision with his eyes so
please go out and hit up graphic guard
follow him and they also have a podcast
Retro Retro Renegade
um I I think that's on Thursdays or
Tuesdays I might be wrong a goal follow
the show is at 7 p.m uh great guys great
stuff remember retro Renegades go do
that
um everybody that purchased the shirt
thank you I appreciate you I appreciate
everybody because we do this to give
back and Inspire shout out to MAV that
did the video
um the the rap song If it's inspiration
we are here to inspire and have
everybody go be the best person that you
can be thank you for everybody that came
out for combat talk with the King that
was a huge success for a little known
Fighters that uh that aren't there that
that aren't known like Canelo and stuff
but you guys came out and hung out and
we had a hundred strong there so thank
you guys I appreciate everything see you
next week all in all with the um with
the Lords attic and I is going to be
moving that to a separate Channel or
putting it behind patreon but we're
going to be continuing you to do the
show up until that point so R and R
Tuesdays 4 30 p.m that's the new time uh
I'm going to go watch uh Fast and the
Furious uh tomorrow uh we're gonna be
talking about mother and um maybe
something else I'm watching Love and
Death on HBO that's a crazy joint with
the the actress that plays The Scholar
which and from them don't forget to
watch white man can't jump through oh
and I gotta watch white man can jump
Attica told me about that that's on Hulu
right now that's the remake of white man
can't jump so I'm going to be watching
that tonight actually as soon as I
finish this but fantastic stuff uh thank
you guys again for rocking out with us
we had 800 plus thank you yeah salute
salute it was a great show I want to
thank my brothers for dealing with my
foolishness today like this is
definitely a bucket list interview I'm
such a fan of Jake's work I never
thought I'd be able to get that
interview the fact that he came on he
filed us and and ended up being one of
our better interviews you know like
we've had a lot of it like he was up
there and like he just said not
naturally charismatic person normal dude
and he's made games yeah
from New York who make them calls you
know what I'm saying
but nah man he's a real one he's a real
one man I'm super proud definitely
bucket list moment for my and shout out
to y'all for really you know asking
great questions and stuff for that
nature shout out to the realm support my
brother King no one no one Hypes the
base up no one inspires people want to
kick inspire me spots everybody so if
anybody taking any type of way that's
you and your feelings you just gotta fix
yourself I don't know what to do with
you that'll get a job get a job so
that's just where I'm at with that let
my brother do his numbers and stop
hating
um at the end of days peace and love we
love everybody um solve we got another
Super Chat and then let's get it
we got Dragonheart yo we try Super Chat
graphic God and retro Renegade 7 P.M
Tuesdays salute graphic uh fantastic job
greeny the team everybody rock with a
salute we will see you next I know
actually before that we got the
PlayStation live showcase please don't
miss that yeah we got that and then
we're gonna hit you with another one
next Sunday we out yeah
next week but the week after will be the
Xbox prediction yes so we got a big one
for that all right y'all we out of here
peace
foreign
[Music]